[Musique]
bonjour à tous c'est l'événement du jour
est l'une des auditions les plus
attendus de la commission d' enquête
lancée à la suite de la sphère benalla
le sénat entend ce matin alexis colère
le secrétaire général de l'elysée proche
parmi elle est proche des manuels macron
les sénateurs vont avoir de nombreuses
questions à lui poser dysfonctionnements
de l'elysée d'ailleurs déjà admis par
emmanuel macron sur l'organisation aussi
de la sécurité présidentielle
la proportion est la réalité de la
sanction alors que patrick strzoda hier
le directeur de cabinet des manuels
macron a indiqué au sénat qu'alexandre
benalla avait touché l'intégralité de
son salaire de mai et on va tout de
suite rejoindre jérôme rabelais notre
journaliste en direct devant la salle
clemenceau va se dérouler cette audition
jérôme c'est une audition très attendue
oui effectivement un tamm tellement
attendu qu'il y avait énormément de
journalistes un instant lors de
l'arrivée d'alexis colère alexis colère
un intime du chef de l'état plutôt
habitué au travail de l'ombre et c'est
les sénateurs veulent l'interroger
car les seules paroles publiques pour
l'instant d'alexis kohler elles se
résument aux annonces de la composition
du gouvernement sur le perron de
l'elysée celui que certains surnomment
le deuxième cerveau des manuels macron
est plutôt du genre taiseux
il est l'homme de confiance des manuels
macron dont il était déjà le directeur
de cabinet au ministère de l'économie
dès 2014 l'assemblée nationale ne le
convoquera pas après le refus des élus
de la république en marche hier qu'à
cela ne tienne les sénateurs ont convié
les députés à venir entendre
l'audition des manuels de d'alexis
kohler et il compte bien lui poser
toutes les questions y compris celles
qui fâchent
beaucoup nous ont confié attendre avec
impatience cette audition et anecdotes
plutôt sympathique
alexis kohler il sera interrogé par un
de ses prédécesseurs à l'elysée puisque
philippe bas le président de cette
commission denquête a été secrétaire
général de l'elysée
le sous jacques chirac il aura notamment
à coeur de savoir si oui ou non il y a
eu des erreurs de commises au sein du
palais présidentiel
et qu'y avez-vous vu arriver qu'il
depuis ce matin jérôme il ya de
nombreuses personnalités notamment un
marine le pen
alors on a vu arriver ici tous les
membres de cette commission philippe bas
le président muriel jourda l'accord à
porter accompagné également de jean
pierre sueur autre rapporteur de cette
commission d' enquête et il ya eu des
invités surprises puisque marine le pen
s'est présenté pour faire une
déclaration dénonce encore une fois le
refus de l'assemblée nationale de
convoquer alexis kohler et devant la
commission denquête de l'assemblée
nationale eh bien les venus pour
entendre alexis kohler ici au sénat
merci beaucoup jérôme un marine le pen
donc l'une des personnalités présentes
la députée qui est là effectivement
puisque pour l'instant et bien alexis
kohler il n'est pas prévu calexico leur
soient entendus à l'assemblée nationale
je vous rappelle quelques éléments de
contexte sur cette audition que vous
allez pouvoir suivre en direct et dans
quelques instants sur public sénat je
vous rappelle que entendus mardi à
l'assemblée nationale et hier au sénat
le directeur de cabinet du président de
la république patrick strzoda a indiqué
avoir averti
alexis colère des agissements de
l'ancien chargé de mission alexandre
benalla lors des manifestations du 1er
mai est tout de suite
eh bien on va rejoindre la salle
clémenceau puisque l'audition est en
train de débuter derrière moi c'est
philippe bas le président ait l'air de
la commission des lois qui est en train
de s'exprimer sur le président sueur
madame muriel jourda pour d'une part
faire la lumière sur l'enchaînement des
faits puis des décisions qui ont eu lieu
à partir du très regrettable incident du
1er mai place de la contrescarpe à de
paris qui a mis en cause la
participation d'un collaborateur du
président de la république à une
opération de maintien de l'ordre
la commission des lois par un vote
unanime du sénat lundi a obtenu les
pouvoirs d'investigation
une commission denquête toute personne
qui ferait obstruction à nos travaux qui
refuseraient d'y participer alors
qu'elle a été convoquée qui mentiraient
à la commission pourraient faire l'objet
de sanctions pénales et nous avons accès
à toutes les pièces qui sont nécessaires
à l'établissement de la vérité dans le
champ des compétences qui nous ont été
données par le sénat qui commission des
lois a décidé que les auditions seraient
publiques avec la présence de la presse
dans le cadre de la mission qui nous a
été confiée par le sénat la commission
des lois s'attachent à établir autant
qu'il est possible
la vérité des faits sa tâche a levé les
contradictions qui ont pu apparaître
dans différentes expressions publiques
elle s'attache aussi à apporter des
précisions quand les réponses qui sont
faites sont trop flou trop trop vague
mais je tiens à le dire chers collègues
pas pour vous mais pour le secrétaire
général comme pour toutes les
personnalités que nous avons entendu
notre commission n'est pas un tribunal
et nous dit si on n'est pas une
comparution
l'objectif de nos travaux n'est pas de
prononcer des condamnations ou des
sanctions l'objectif de nos travaux
c'est l'établissement
devant les français de la vérité c'est
circonscrire les zones nombre que nous
n'aurons pas réussi à éclairer et qui
poseront encore des interrogations s'il
en reste
et c'est faire des propositions des
recommandations des préconisations pour
améliorer le fonctionnement de l'état
dans le respect de la séparation des
pouvoirs et nous considérons que bien
sûr l'essentiel dans la séparation des
pouvoirs c'est la distinction entre
l'exécutif le législatif la justice mais
il ya d'autres éléments essentiels pour
la séparation des pouvoirs il existe en
france au sein de l'exécutif deux
pouvoirs constitutionnels qui font
l'objet de titres différents dans la
constitution le pouvoir du président de
la république le pouvoir du gouvernement
et le gouvernement a seule autorité sur
l'administration c'est pourquoi toute
interférence la collaborateurs du
président de la république avec
fonctionnement d'une administration
quelle qu'elle soit en l'occurrence
l'administration de la police est un
grave désordre
nous chercherons à améliorer le
fonctionnement de l'état dans les cadres
de l'eso de l'état de droit et de la
tradition républicaine pour que notre
commission denquête soit utile pourquoi
nous soulevons toutes les questions sur
les dysfonctionnements administratifs
les entorses à la répartition des
pouvoirs constitutionnels entre le
président de la république et le
gouvernement mais aussi des questions
particulières sur l'organisation de la
sécurité du président de la république
parce que la sécurité du président de la
république n'est pas que la sphère du
président de la république
par souci de d'assurer les garanties
nécessaires pour le bon fonctionnement
de nos institutions et la continuité de
l'état
il est essentiel que la protection du
président de la république soit assurée
par des fonctionnaires civils et
militaires qu'ils soient recrutés formés
entraînés évalué coordonné par un
service de l'état
nous savons monsieur le secrétaire
général qu'à cet égard vous avez reçu
une mission qui vient prolonger des
travaux qui étaient déjà engagés nous
aurons d'ailleurs à vous demander quel à
suffisance sont récemment apparues qui
pourrait justifier que les travaux
engagés sous l'autorité du directeur de
cabinet vous soit désormais confiées
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire en
commençant cette audition je laisse la
possibilité aux personnalités convoquées
d'ouvrir leur propre audition par un
propos liminaire que je souhaite
bref je poserai ensuite moi même
quelques questions
même s'il ya lieu je donnerai ensuite la
parole another à porter il vous en
poseront aussi et viendra le tour chers
collègues de chacune et chacun d'entre
vous vous manifesterez en cours
d'audition est entendu que seuls les
commissaires aux lois participent des
pouvoirs de commission d' enquête qui
nous ont été dévolues ils ont la
priorité pour vous poser des questions
ce qui n'exclut pas mes chers collègues
non membre de la commission des lois je
sais que vous êtes nombreux ici que vous
puissiez à votre tour poser des
questions dont je précise qu'elles n'ont
pas le même statut que les questions
posées par la commission des lois
voilà je crois que j'ai à peu près dit
tout ce que je vais devait dire mais je
dois monsieur le secrétaire général
d'abord vous demander de prêter serment
je rappelle qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission des lois doté des
prérogatives d'une commission denquête
serait passible de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
damende je vous invite un prêté serment
de dire toute la vérité rien
que la vérité levé la main droite et dit
je le jure je le jure monsieur le
secrétaire général vous avez la parole
si vous souhaitez la prendre je remercie
monsieur le président madame la cause la
reprise puisse le co-rapporteur mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs je me
contenterai de quelques mots
introductifs très bref tout d'abord je
tiens à commencer par souscrire
pleinement vos réponses qui vous ont été
apportées hier par le directeur de
cabinet du président de la république
patrick strzoda qui comme vous le savez
tous et un préfet de très grande
expérience dans le sens de l'état et
reconnu par tous et qui a toute ma
confiance
j'ajoute que je considère que c'est une
grande chance pour moi comme secrétaire
général la présence de la république de
pouvoir compter sur son concours
quotidien
comme vous l'a également indiqué patrick
strzoda
le président de la république a autorisé
certains de ses collaborateurs à venir
devant vous afin de contribuer à la
manifestation de la vérité
il m'a néanmoins demandé de rappeler le
cadre juridique dans lequel s'inscrit
cette audition il me semble en
particulier déterminant de souligner
vous avez fait vous même monsieur
président l'importance du respect de la
séparation des pouvoirs auxquels nous
sommes tous attachés qui me permettra
pas de répondre aux questions portant
sur les faits donnant lieu à des
poursuites judiciaires ou à celle
portant sur l'organisation interne de la
présidence de la république
j'en viens à présent à l'objet même de
votre commission et aux événements du
1er mai j'ai passé l'après-midi du 1er
mai dernier à mon bureau le directeur de
cabinet m'a tenu informé du déroulement
des manifestations et des opérations de
maintien de l'ordre
je rappelle que ces manifestations se
sont révélés d'une ampleur
exceptionnelle au regard des violences
commises des commerces saccagés des
dégradations constatées et d un perte
interpellations auxquelles les forces de
l'ordre ont procédé
je me saisis cette occasion pour saluer
l'engagement sans faille des forces de
l'ordre et le professionnalisme dont
elles ont fait preuve au cours de ces
événements la question des événements de
la place de la contrescarpe now n'a à
aucun moment été mentionné
j'ai été informé le lendemain le 2 mai
dans la matinée par le conseiller en
charge notamment des réseaux sociaux et
le directeur de cabinet de la
publication sous les réseaux sociaux
d'une vidéo dans laquelle un individu
qui sa part s apparenter à monsieur
benalla se livrer à des actes
inappropriés et choquants dans le cadre
des opérations de maintien de l'ordre
sur la place de la contrescarpe à ce
moment le directeur de cabinet mme
indique qu'il a d'ores et déjà convoqué
l'intéressé qui a reconnu sa présence
sur les lieux et sa participation des
interprétations je m'assure que le
directeur de cabinet a bien vérifié
auprès de la préfecture de police et du
cabinet du ministre de l'intérieur de la
réalité des faits est retracée dans la
vidéo et qui évidemment sont bien la
forme nous refaisons le point en fin de
journée constatant que les faits sont
bien avérée le directeur de cabinet
m'informe de son intention d'appliquer
une sanction disciplinaire sans délai ce
qui me semble totalement approprié nous
nous reparlons le lendemain et le
directeur de cabinet ma forme de la
sanction qu'ils entendent notifié à
l'agent et donc il vous a parlé hier la
suspension de quinze jours avec votre
salaire la modification des
responsabilités confiées à l'intéressé
la notification portée au dossier
l'indication que tout nouveau
comportement fautif entraînerait un
licenciement qu'ils aient lieu par la
suite
compte tenu des éléments portés à notre
connaissance à ce moment là la sanction
apparaît proportionnée
au bout du compte la sanction a été
décidée dès le jour de la découverte des
faits est notifiée à l'intéressé
dès le lendemain j'ajoute un point
compte tenu de l'audition du directeur
de cabinet patrick strzoda hier devant
vous et devant les députés de celle du
commandant militaire du palais de
l'elysée le général bio farina et du
chef du j espère le colonel lavergne
je pense j'espère que vous avez été
rassuré sur le fait qu'il n'existe pas à
l'elysée de police parallèle que nous
n'employons pas de vigiles privés pour
protéger le chef de l'état et que
monsieur benalla n'a jamais été en
charge de la protection du président de
la république je vous remercie et sur
votre disposition pour répondre à
l'ensemble de vos questions
merci monsieur le secrétaire général de
ce tour préliminaire
il ya un point que vous n'avez pas
spontanément abordés mais qui me paraît
utile de préciser pour que l'ensemble de
mes collègues comprennent votre rôle
auprès du chef de l'état vous exercer
une fonction dont j'entends dire qu'elle
est très importante
mais c'est une fonction qui n'est pas
public d'une certaine façon car mise à
part une exception jamais le secrétaire
général de la présidence de la
république ne s'exprime publiquement
sauf pour lire sur le perron de l'élysée
la liste des membres du gouvernement ce
qui lui assure une grande notoriété mais
elle n'est que temporaire mes collègues
et nos concitoyens qui suivent nos
travaux sont certainement impatients que
vous puissiez pour éclairer le contexte
7 et 10 positions expliqué ce que vous
faites
[Musique]
monsieur le président je vous remercie
une certaine manière nous permettre
d'accéder à une certaine notoriété
cette occasion au delà de notoriété
furtif que m'a donné la possibilité
d'énumérer la liste des membres du
gouvernement sur le perron de l'elysée
et vous avez raison de rappeler que
j'aurais probablement dû commencer par
rappeler en quoi consiste mais les
fonctions qui sont les miennes comme ce
qu intervient la présence de la
république
comme vous le savez vous même si vous
allez occuper ce poste
le secrétaire-général et n'est pas pour
moi que je posais la question non je
viens d'entendre j'ai bien entendu le
skate en général et le collaborateur
direct du président de la république
probablement son principal collaborateur
et pilote l'action de la présidence et
des équipes de la présidence en
particulier en ce qui concerne les
politiques publiques et évidemment
chacun dans son rôle en lien avec
le premier ministre et le gouvernement
pour ce faire le secrétaire général
s'appuie sur différentes organisations
ou partis du cabinet ou des services de
la présidence
en particulier l'état major particulier
du président de la république pour ce
qui concerne les questions de défense
le pôle diplomatique pour ce qui
concerne la question des questions
touchant aux affaires étrangères le pôle
e régalien possible des questions
intérieures ou territoriales et les
équipes du du cabinet qui sont chargés
de conseiller le président de la
république dans les différents domaines
de l'action publique que je n'ai
numéraire et pas par ailleurs au delà du
cabinet du président la république
la présidence est une assez grande
maison vous pourrez trouver tous les
détails dans le rapport de la cour des
comptes sur sa gestion pour l'année 2010
est qui a été publié ce faire de ma part
avant-hier avec le premier président est
venu présenter au présent la public
avant-hier et vous verrez que les
services de la présidence de la public
compte un peu plus de 800 personnes en
ce compris des services dont je pense
qu'on aura l'occasion de lire un mot
aujourd'hui comme le commandement
militaire du palais qui assurent
l'intégrité la sécurité des bâtiments
l'entretien le
le gspr pour la sécurité du président de
la république d'une grande quantité de
services supports qui permettent de
faire fonctionner cette cette maison
enfin pour ce qui concerne la gestion
interne de la présidence de la
république en particulier la gestion de
son personnel la gestion de son de son
budget et d'une façon générale toute
question qui touche vraiment à
l'organisation y compris sur les
questions de sécurité le scrutin général
s'appuie sur le directeur de cabinet que
vous avez auditionné hier au cas
d'espèce patrick strzoda et qui me rend
compte c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour
laquelle je ne vous ferai pas de réponse
aussi détaillé que celle que patrick
strzoda a pu vous faire hier
ou aussi technique puisque il est
véritablement en charge de la gestion
interne de la maison
encore une fois on me rends dans le
conte et de manière quotidienne
voilà j'espère avoir répondu à la
question donnez à votre question au nom
de vos collègues je vous remercie
monsieur le secrétaire général
secrétaire général le 2 mai dernier une
sanction est donc prise à l'encontre de
monsieur benalla mais ce jour là la
sanction se limite à une mise à pied de
quinze jours assortie des différents
éléments que vous avez rappelé à
l'instant dont un prélèvement sur le
salaire dont nous avons appris hier
qu'il n'avait pas encore eu lieu mais ce
jour là il n'est pas mis fin aux
fonctions de monsieur benalla ethnie à
la présidence de la république ni au
gouvernement ni à la préfecture de
police
on ne signale les faits au parquet je
voulais vous demander si
rétrospectivement
vous avez conscience des risques que
pouvaient faire courir au chef de l'état
le maintien dans l'effectif de la
présidence de la république d'un
individu qui avait révélé de tels
comportements est-ce que vous avez pris
conscience de la gravité du trouble
apporter au fonctionnement de l'état par
l'abus de la qualité de collaborateur du
chef de l'état dans l'intrusion qui
s'était produite dans la hiérarchie de
la police à l'occasion d'une opération
de maintien de l'ordre
est ce que vous avez à ce moment là où
maintenant pris conscience de la
nécessité de réexaminer l'articulation
entre les collaborateurs du président de
la république et les services du
gouvernement pour que la séparation des
pouvoirs entre présidence de la
république et gouvernement
soit désormais mieux assurée merci
monsieur pas ce dont il ne fait aucun
doute et je dois dire que sur cette
question il n'y a eu aucun doute il n'y
a eu aucun débat au sein de la
présidence de la république
lorsque les faits ont été connus sur le
fait que c'est fait costil était non
seulement inappropriée choquant comme je
les dis mais également constituer une
faute
j'insiste sur ce point et aucun
malentendu je n'ai véritablement eu
aucune discussion sur ce sujet il était
de l'ordre de l'évidence pour tout le
monde que le comportement de monsieur
benalla devait être sanctionné j'ajoute
sur plus qu' il était évident pour tout
le monde que cette sanction devait
intervenir rapidement et c'est la raison
pour laquelle l'enchaînement des faits
est assez rapide puisque immédiatement
après le journal de la connaissance des
fêtes
la décision est prise et lui notifier le
lendemain cette sanction doit être
semble-t-il apprécié à la lumière des
faits et des éléments dont
nous disposions à l'époque nous
disposions à l'époque en tout cas à mon
niveau et compte tenu des discussions
que j'ai pu avoir avec le directeur de
cabinet de la vidéo qui avaient circulé
sur les sur les réseaux sociaux du
contexte de violence particulier des
manifestations du 1er mai et des
informations qui ont pu nous être
communiquées par le ministère de
l'intérieur la préfecture de police et m
communiquer par l'intermédiaire de deux
directeurs de cabinet la vidéo montre
d'abord la participation de monsieur
benalla à cette manifestation équipé
d'un casque qui évidemment ne manque pas
de susciter pour le moins des questions
et le jour même il m'a été confirmé que
la préfecture de police
accueillez de nombreux observateurs et
que pour les accueillir
elle leur fournissait leurs équipements
je note que c'est un point qui m'a été
dit d'emblée mais qui par la suite a été
a été confirmée a été en particulier
confirmé par le préfet de police
lorsqu'il a été auditionné devant
l'assemblée nationale a aussi été
confirmée de manière plus détaillée par
le commandant militaire du palais
monsieur bio-farina lorsqu il relaté une
conversation à laquelle il a assisté en
tout état de cause il a dès la confier
aux polices accueille régulièrement des
observateurs et les équipes de ce point
de vue là l'équipement d'un d'un cas ce
que semblait correspondre à la pratique
habituelle mais j'ai vu depuis lors dans
la presse
des photographies d'autres observateurs
plus lourdement équipés
deuxièmement la vidéo montre que
monsieur benalla a participé à
l'interpellation d'un manifestant là
aussi on en droit de s'interroger
il m'a été indiqué que cette
interpellation certes musclée ne montrez
pas trop violent n'infliger pas de
blessure et cette analyse à me
semble-t-il été confirmée de lierre ou
avant-hier par la directrice le l'igpn
qui a décrit ces circonstances il n'a
par ailleurs été indiqué que les
personnes interpellées n'avait pas fait
l'objet dit été ou de dépôt de plainte
troisièmement la vidéo rend compte de
manière partielle depuis leur complétée
par d'autres vidéos du contexte
particulier les violences non seulement
ce jour là j'en ai parlé mais également
sur la place de la contrescarpe il m'a
été confirmé que c'était un niveau de
violence exceptionnelle et que les
personnes interpellées avaient
effectivement agresser les forces de
l'ordre c'est un point qu'il aussi était
confirmée par différentes vidéos
par la suite c'est un élément de
contexte important il m'a été dit par la
suite qu'il y avait eu trente et une
interpellation place de la contrescarpe
ce soir là sur 276 au cours de la
journée nous tels sont les éléments dont
nous disposions de le mans secrétaire je
vous interromps juste vous remercie
d'être très précis dans les éléments
d'information dont nous on veut nous
fournissez moi ma question c'était les
deux mais monsieur benalla se voit
infliger une sanction mais il n'est pas
mis fin à ses fonctions
il n'est pas décidé de saisir la justice
est ce que vous aviez conscience le 2
mai ou es ce que vous avez pris
conscience depuis lors des risques que
faisait courir au président de la
république le maintien d'une telle
collaboration avec un agent qui s'était
ainsi comporter est ce que vous avez eu
conscience à ce moment là
ou pris conscience depuis de la gravité
du trouble apporter au fonctionnement de
l'état par l'intrusion d'un
collaborateur du président de la
république dans une opération de
maintien de l'ordre à laquelle il a
participé
et est ce que vous avez pris conscience
de ce fait de l'utilité qu'il y aurait à
réexaminer les modalités générales de la
collaboration entre les services de la
présidence de la république et les
administrations placée sous l'autorité
du gouvernement voilà ma question non
encore une fois je ne me connais
absolument pas la gravité des faits ni
ce jour là ni aujourd'hui ce qui aurait
été particulièrement grave et ce qui
aurait porté atteinte la présence de la
public de façon particulièrement aiguës
graves souhaité qu'il n'y aurait pas eu
de réaction n'est pas une sanction
et c'est pour ça qu'on a encore une fois
insisté pour qu'il ne sanctionne que ce
soit rapide
et pour ce qui est de l'article 40
compte tenu des éléments dont je dispose
et je n'avais pas les éléments me
permettant de penser qu'une saisine au
titre de l'article 40 serait justifié
j'ajoute pour être plus explicite
vous avez cité un nombre d'autorités qui
ont été informés
au niveau du gouvernement ou ailleurs et
qu'aucune autorité qui ait eu à
connaître de ces faits n'a à ma
connaissance
elles ont même suggéré l'opportunité
d'un article 40 et je crois que le
directeur de cabinet nous a par ailleurs
répondu en détail sur ce point et sur
l'analyse qu'il a lui-même fait je
conçois parfaitement qu aujourd'hui à la
lumière des fêtes est connu depuis lors
dont certains je le rappelle ont conduit
au licenciement de monsieur benalla
puisque dans le courrier de notification
de la sanction il lui a été dit qu'à la
prochaine faute ils seraient licenciés
de manière à ce que mon une réponse qui
soit proportionné graduée qui nous
restent certainement pas sans
conséquences dès lors que de nouveaux
faits se produirait ça a été le cas et
donc je maintiens que la lumière des
faits connus depuis la sanction peut
apparaître insuffisante mais que
symétriquement au regard des éléments
connus le 2 mai
cette sanction était proportionné et
j'ajoute que j'ai entendu hier éric
morvan le dgpn qui a indiqué hier devant
les députés que placé dans la même
situation il aurait probablement pris la
même décision
c'est votre réponse monsieur le
secrétaire général alors je voulais vous
poser une deuxième question vous l'avez
dit vous-même tout à l'heure c'est un
point de vue que vous défendez monsieur
benhadda n'exerçait pas de fonction de
protection personnelle
le directeur du cabinet du président de
la république nous a expliqué m les
trois missions qui sont dans sa
définition de fonction qu'elle a fait
l'objet d'une note que nous avons
demandé dans ces trois fonctions il y a
le déplacement privé du chef de l'état
nous avons fait l'hypothèse que ces
déplacements privés donné lieu à la mise
en oeuvre d'une forme de sécurité
adaptées à leur nature
c'est d'ailleurs une hypothèse qui nous
a été confirmée mais que monsieur
benalla à ce moment là doté d'un port
d'ars pouvait accompagner le président
de la république et assurer sa
protection
mais il nous a été dit que ça n'était
pas le cas et du coup de nous sommes
interrogés sur l'utilité du port d'armes
qui lui a été attribué par ce qui nous a
aussi est indiqué que dans les
déplacements officiels du chef de l'état
il n'avait jamais son arme
le préfet de police s'est inquiété de
savoir si il avait avec lui son arme
pendant les manifestations du 1er mai
mais il n'y avait pas de réponse à cette
interrogation qu'il se faisait à lui
même je voudrais savoir au nombre de la
commission qu'elle était dans la mesure
où vous pouvez l'expliquer sans porter
préjudice à la sécurité du président de
la république
bien sûr mais quelle était la nature du
travail fait par monsieur ben alla pour
les déplacements privés du président de
la république
et si oui ou non
il accompagnait le président de la
république avec une dimension de
protection personnelle pendant ses
déplacements privés
alors comme vous l'a indiqué le prix
stendhal hier alexandre benalla était
chargé de mission auprès de la chefferie
de cabinet c'est à dire auprès de
l'entité qui au sein du cabinet présent
la république et chargé d'organiser son
agenda ses déplacements
et de s'assurer que tous les services
qui doivent concourir à l'exercice de sa
mission ou de ses déplacements que ce
soit en matière de sécurité de
communication de transport suis qu'un et
c'était bien la fonction d'alexandre
benalla qui était donc à la chefferie et
qui n'était pas en charge de la sécurité
il était donc en charge de l'interaction
entre la chefferie de cabinet qui doit
coordonner l'ensemble de ces éléments et
les personnes en charge de la sécurité
il y a deux types de service comme vous
le savez qui sont en charge de la
sécurité le président de la république
soit 15 il ya d'une part un peu fouillis
caméra qui se fout il ya de ne pas le
commandement militaire du palais qui est
en charge de l'intégrité des bâtiments
et de la sécurité du président à
l'intérieur des résidences
présidentielles
d'une part et qui est dirigé par le
général bien fine il y à part dont le
général bio-farina eric bio vendangés de
secrétaire général
je précise le pr n'est pas en mauvaise
part chers collègues vous n'avez pas
répondre aux interpellations des
collègues pendant le cours de vos
explications devant merci et d'autre
part le groupement de sécurité présentes
à un public
donc on me signale qu'on ne vous entend
pas toujours bien d'en approcher du lait
rapprocher par don de la médiocrité de
notre équipement
le d'autre part le j espère et qui
dirigé par le colonel lavergne et qui
accompagne le président de la république
dans ses déplacements
la sécurité du président de la
république est toujours assurée pendant
en toute circonstance par l'une de ces
deux unités
c'est véritablement le commandement
militaire et le j'espère qu'ils sont en
charge et j'ajoute que ses services sont
exclusivement qui vient exclusivement
composée de personnels qui sont qui
relève soit de la police soit de la
gendarmerie
et ce sont eux qui sont responsables de
la sécurité
le président de la république je pense
que ce sont des points qui ont été me
semble-t-il clarifié par les auditions
du général bio-farina du colonel
lavergne à l'assemblée nationale jeudi
je crois parce qu'elles ont eu lieu
pendant le conseil des ministres auquel
j'assiste et donc je n'ai pas pu les
voir du moins en direct et pour que ce
soit bien clair s'agissant de
l'interaction entre alexandre benalla et
ses services exemple à la n'appartenait
n'appartient ni au commandement
militaire ni aux j'espère
il n'avait pas de responsabilité
les concernant ils n'étaient pas
pressenti pour occuper un poste de
responsabilité concernant services comme
j'ai pu le lire
ici ou là c'est le secrétaire général
qui ne s'explique pas si messieurs bnl
là n'avaient pas une fonction que je
déchire et que je définirais
sommairement comme celle d'un garde du
corps
et si ils n'étaient pas habilités à
porter une arme pendant les déplacements
officiels
s'il n'en portait pas non plus pendant
les déplacements privés pourquoi la
présidence de la république et les
services du ministère de l'intérieur qui
ont instruit cette demande
ont-elles favoriser l'obtention d'un
permis de port d'armes
il ya là est pour nous une sorte d'
incohérences qu'elle pouvait être
l'utilité pour la présidence de la
république que cet agent est un permis
de port d'armes
j'ai oublié de vous êtes vous avez
raison que le président de me lancer sur
la question du port d'armes qui est une
question avec lui je n'ai pas répondu et
à laquelle je dois commencer par
répondre que je n'ai pas eu à connaître
de la question du port d'armé élections
de banana simplement parce que comme je
vous l'indiquais le compte tenu des
responsabilités qui sont les miennes je
ne nous on pourra les deux questions
même si encore une fois je pense que ce
sont des questions qui ne relèvent pas
du champ de cette commission en tout cas
qu'ils enlèvent très clairement de
l'organisation interne des services la
présence d'un public mais en tout état
de cause je n'ai pas eu à connaître de
cette de l'attribution des modalités
d'attribution de port d'armes à monsieur
benalla mais aussi bien me semble-t-il
le préfet de police que le directeur de
cabinet est présent dans le public vous
on vous en répondu sur ce point est à la
fois dans les modalités de l'attribution
par la préfecture de police donc du
cadre juridique dans laquelle
s'inscrivent et il me semble que ce
cadre
j'aurais dit qu est liée à la fonction
et non pas lorsque si ç'avait été une
attribution par le ministère de
l'intérieur liés à un risque
le concernant tout particulièrement et
ça n'était pas le cas nous venons
justement qu'est-ce qui dans sa fonction
grande est utile pour la présidence de
la république que monsieur benalla est
un permis de port d'armes
franchement je suppose tout simplement
que comme vous l'avait indiqué le
dispositif de sécurité est adapté à
l'intensité de la de la menace et au
contexte dans lequel se situe le
président de la république il est
toujours j'insiste il est toujours oui
tout à fait il y à des services et ce
sont toujours ces services qui sont en
charge
c'est toujours le gspr qui est en charge
lorsque le présent d'un public est en
déplacement
je pense simplement je suppose que dans
certaines circonstances il était jugé
qu' il pouvait être utile que d'autres
puissent apporter leur concours
mais vous les interrogez il ne reste pas
moins j insiste sur ce point monsieur le
sénateur parce que vous avez l'air de
trouver ça curieux mais c'est ainsi
c'est toujours le j'espère qu'ils aient
sur la protection président la
république le chef de jesper il a dit
merci monsieur le secrétaire général
madame mûriers le jourdain qui est
rapporteur de notre mission
d'information va vous poser quelques
questions à son tour merci monsieur le
président monsieur le secrétaire général
vous nous avez rappelé à l'instar de
monsieur directeur de cabinet qu
effectivement monsieur benalla ne fait
pas partie du service de sécurité
rapprochée du président de la république
je crois qu'il aurait fallu lui en
informer parce que chacun a en tête
l'image au salon de l'agriculture où
dans un geste stupide quelqu'un j'ai
stage atteint 9 sur le président de la
république et le premier qui est là et
dans un geste de protection physique à
l'égard du président de la république
c'est monsieur bédard
c'est monsieur b dallas si on rajoute à
cela qu effectivement il un port d'armes
pour lequel nous avons bien du mal il
faut dire à obtenir des explications
il a une voiture de police on le voit
systématiquement auprès du président de
la république dans des occasions privées
comme publiques enfin c'est mon
agriculture je les dis mais en faisant
du vélo au panthéon au 14 juillet et
j'en passe
vous ne pensez vous pas qu
indépendamment du fait que vous nous
indiquiez fermement que la sécurité
rapprochée du président de la république
est assurée par des fonctionnaires
civils et militaires
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il ait pu y avoir
une confusion de fait y compris dans
l'esprit de monsieur benalla et
éventuellement dans l'esprit de ces
professionnels que sont les
fonctionnaires civils et militaires qui
sont chargés de la sécurité rapprochée
du président
alors je vous remercie en pâtissent
cette question je ne me prononcerai pas
sur la confusion qui pourrait y avoir
dans l'esprit de monsieur b dallas qui
je le rappelle néanmoins à une à
participer de la mission de sécurité des
manuels macron lorsque il accueillit il
a comme président de du parti en marche
puis ensuite le pendant la campagne
présidentielle
dès lors que le ministère de l'intérieur
n'avait pas souhaité accorder à emmanuel
macron une protection et donc durant
cette période effectivement
alexandre bédat a participé les missions
de sécurité
je pense du reste il faudrait vérifier
que la scène que vous décrivez au salon
de l'agriculture je me demande si c'est
pas une scène qui datent d'ailleurs de
la campagne électorale fait cela ce n 2
de l'offre en particulier me semble
davantage datait de la campagne
électorale est pas de sa dernière visite
mais peu importe
mais juste pour signaler que à un moment
donné de sa carrière et à une époque où
le président rappelait qu'il n'était pas
présent la république alexandre blain a
une mission de sécurité auprès de lui en
revanche je puis vous assurer que il n'y
a pas de confusion dans l'esprit des
services de sécurité de la présence de
la république et qu'il n'y a pas de
confusion dans l'esprit de chef du
j'espère parce que vous faites référence
un déplacement à l'extérieur du palais
sur le fait que c'est bien lui et ses
équipes qui sont en charge de la
protection du président des techniques
je n'ai aucun doute là dessus je pense
d'ailleurs qu'il l'a très clairement
très clairement rappelé de lorsqu'il a
été auditionné à l'assemblée
madame jourdain une autre question oui
de toujours sur sur ce point
effectivement vous nous dit qu'il n'ya
pas de confusion dans l'esprit du chef
du j'espère vous le savez nous avons
entendu ici des syndicats de policiers
assez nombreux qui nous ont tous fait
part dans des termes assez variés du
fait que monsieur v dallas auraient pris
une importance assez considérable au
point parfois de vouloir prendre la main
sur un certain nombre de services de
sécurité et c'est en ça que je parle de
confusion de fait même s'il n'avait pas
vous nous dites et nous de mankono
raison de ne pas vous croire qu'il n'a
pas en droit la possibilité de prendre
la main sur ces services de sécurité
avez vous été informé d'une façon ou
d'une autre de ces éléments qui sont
venus de façon assez unanime alors très
clairement van damme accord aboutisse la
réponse est non
lorsque
alors j'ai bien évidemment ua à
connaître du recrutement de monsieur
benalla comme comme chargé de mission et
compte tenu de ses qualités unanimement
reconnues d'organisateurs son
recrutement était jugée légitime et
utile je ne reviens pas sur ce point
d'ailleurs nous présente la république a
eu l'occasion hier en marge d'un
déplacement de rappeler ce point je n'en
ai pas non plus sur ces sur ses missions
j'ajoute que je sois bien clair je n'ai
jamais eu à titre personnel à travailler
directement avec monsieur benalla au
cours de la période où il a été employé
la présence à un public mais je peux
vous dire que à aucun moment je n'ai été
informé du moindre incident ou
comportements inadaptés de l'intéressé
jusqu'au 2 mai à aucun moment et je vous
dirais même le contraire
je n'ai eu que des retours positifs sur
le travail l'engagement là le dévouement
de de monsieur bénard et sans trahir me
semble-t-il
le sentiment général je crois pouvoir
vous dire que monsieur bédard était très
apprécié de ses collègues
donc je n'ai jamais eu le moindre retour
négatif sur ce point est par ailleurs
j'ai entendu dire que il aurait eu je
cite terroriser des services de la
présidence
mais le chef de ces services de me
semble-t-il il est lui-même répondu ce
n'est pas le cas ou si c'était le cas en
tout cas ça n'a jamais été portée
à sa connaissance comme chef de service
ni à la mine
ce sont les syndicats certains syndicats
de policiers qui ont fait un nom pas de
la terreur manifesté par ressenti et par
des agents de la présidence de la
république mais plutôt par les services
de police extérieur à l'elysée lors des
déplacements présidentiels nous avons
demandé que les informations qui nous
était ainsi donnée soit source et est
précisée mais les faits pour l'instant
ne sont en effet pas établie nous
entendons votre réponse
simplement il n'est pas impossible que
nous ayons de plus en plus
d'informations sur ce point quand deux
ce qui nous a été dit sur le fait que
des langues se délient ray bien qu'elle
se délient madame jourdain
monsieur le président en sueur merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
secrétaire général je voulais d'abord
revenir sur votre propos introductif
comme je lé fais hier vous avez fait
état de l'autorisation qui vous a été
donné par le président de la république
de venir ici répondre à nos questions je
voulais vous dire ma conception en vertu
de laquelle cette autorisation n'était
pas nécessaire n'était pas utile et elle
n'a pas d'effet pour la raison simple
que nous considérons que tout citoyen
doit en vertu de la constitution venir
répondre aux questions d'une commission
d' enquête parlementaire
dès lors qu'il y est convié à la seule
exception du président de la république
que nous n'avons jamais pensé
contrairement à d'autres a invité à
solliciter monsieur le président
car nous sommes comme vous même et comme
vous l'avez dit très attaché à la
séparation des pouvoirs et aux principes
de notre vème république
ceci étant précisé je voulais revenir
sur la question de l'article 40
je remarque mes chers collègues que en
popularité il y un nouvel article 40 qui
va peut être supplanté un autre article
40 qui est extrêmement populaire si je
puis dire par euphémisme dans les
assemblées parlementaires
vous nous avez dit que vous n'aviez pas
cru devoir saisir la justice donc le
procureur de la république
mais voyez vous nous avons posé cette
question environ six personnes
monsieur le préfet de police a dit qu'
il ne lui appartenait pas de le faire en
raison du fait que monsieur biya l'a
relevé de la présidence de la république
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur nous
a dit la même chose et quand on
interroge bien entendu au plus haut
niveau
les représentants de l'elysée nous avons
la question de la réponse que vous nous
avez donné il peut apparaître au
singulier
jeudi il peut vous savez ici nous sommes
très prudents et nous avons nous avons
raison de l'être que la justice soit
saisie mais d'ailleurs elle s'est auto
saisi dès lors que monsieur benalla a
fait appel à trois fonctionnaires pour
obtenir une vidéo
mais l'acte qui consiste à faire usage
de violence à l'égard de citoyens et de
s'approprier indûment les insignes de la
police nationale peut apparaître quand
même comme étant d'une gravité telle
qu'elle aurait qu'il aurait justifié la
saisine immédiate du procureur de la
république
voilà c'est la première remarque je
voulais faire j'en ajoute une autre
il y a eu donc la mise à pied
je dois dire que depuis l'audition de
monsieur le directeur de cabinet j'ai
reçu un certain nombre de
message de spécialiste du droit du
travail qui s'interroge lourdement pour
savoir s'il est conforme au code du
travail qu une mise à pied avec
réduction de salaire à due concurrence
soient mises en oeuvre sur les congés
non pris
il me semble qu'il ya là quelques
questions juridiques et quelques
implications notamment sur la notion
d'indemnité compensatrice relatives à
des à des congés sur lesquels peut-être
une étude juridique plus approfondie ne
serait pas monsieur le secrétaire
général inutile mais pour revenir à
l'essentiel
monsieur lorsque un fait comme cela
apparaît et je prend bien en compte ce
que vous avez dit sur les services
rendus par monsieur benalla et sur le
fait qu'il a suscité des appréciations
positives mais tout d'un coup il y a une
attitude de sa part qui est quand même
incompréhensible inacceptable ce sont
les propos du président de la république
et qui portent atteinte à l'elysée il
est déchargé de ses fonctions en matière
de protection et de sécurité a dit le
porte-parole de la présidence de la
république
et lorsque sont achevés et là c'est la
question principale que je me permets de
poser mes chers collègues excusez moi
d'être un peu répétitif par rapport à
puisque dauger posé la même question à
d'autres interlocuteurs c'est vrai mais
on a besoin des réponses de chacune et
de chacun
à partir du moment où il a fini les 15
jours de mise à pied
moi j'aurais pensé monsieur le
secrétaire général que l'attitude de
logique eût été de l'exfiltrer en
quelque sorte de toutes tâches relatives
à la protection à la sécurité c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'a dit le porte-parole
or comme l'a dit madame muriel jourda
nous le retrouvons auprès du président
dans des situations extrêmement sensible
et public
je pense au panthéon je pense au 14
juillet je pense à l'arrivée des bleus à
roissy où il ya quelques discussions
avec la gendarmerie etc etc
donc comment pouvez-vous justifier cela
alors monsieur strzoda s'est donné
beaucoup de mal je dois dire pour nous
expliquer que sa fonction numéro 1 avant
la mise à pied étaient d'une nature et
que la fonction numéro deux après une
mise à pied et est d'une autre nature
mais je dois vous dire que sur ce point
je n'ai pas totalement été convaincus
pour traquer trop bien sûr cette
question nationaux secrétaire général à
porter j'ai noté au moins quatre
questions
vous savez j'ai du coup et avec quelques
questions dans les questions donc je
vais essayer malgré tout être
synthétique de marée pour bien sûr
vous avez commencé votre propos en
revenant sur mon propos liminaires sur
l'autorisation de présidera public venu
à ma rencontre devant vous je ne serai
pas long sur ce point néanmoins je crois
devoir y revenir puisque personne
n'ignore que cette question est un sujet
de débat constitutionnel
c'est la raison pour laquelle à ma
connaissance aucun collaborateur du
présent à un public n'a été auditionné
devant des commissions parlementaires
sont au nombre de quatre pendant près de
50 ans et seulement ça a été refusé de
manière systématique pendant près de 50
ans jusqu'à amy a été dé roger pour la
première fois en 2007 et ensuite de
manière exceptionnelle je ne reviens pas
sur l'argumentation et sur la
combinaison des articles 51,2 des
commissions d enquête en lien avec
l'article 24 qui renvoie l'action du
gouvernement et qui du coup fait que
l'interprétation de continuer et que les
commissions de peut-être l'oft a porté
sur l'action de prison la république du
reste juste pour donner un exemple en
2009 quand s'est posé la question d'une
commission d' enquête sur les marchés de
la présidence de la république elle a
été déclarée irrecevable parce qu'elle
touche à l'organisation interne la
présidence de la république et non pas à
l'action du gouvernement
je ferme cette parenthèse nous n'allons
pas tranché ici ce débat constitutionnel
je pense que vous serez d'accord avec
moi pour dire qu'on va le laisser aux
constitutionnalistes à ce stade et c'est
dur est inutile puisque je suis devant
vous pour répondre à vos questions ce
liban mais je préférais néanmoins je
vais enfin je crois important de
rappeler ce principe qui est au coeur de
séparation des pouvoirs
deuxièmement m'avait interrogé sur
l'appréciation
relative à l'article 40
là encore je vais pas revenir sur le les
explications que je vous ai donné à la
mais je rappellerai simplement que la
lumière des éléments dont on dispose et
c'est à dire d'une vidéo dans laquelle
on le voit participer à une opération de
maintien de l'ordre équipées d'un seul
casque
là encore se pose la question de
l'usurpation mai mais était d'emblée
indiqué le directeur de cabinet que j'ai
interrogés qui lui-même s'est renseigné
que c'était parfaitement dans les
pratiques habituelles la préfecture de
police
les clients des opérateurs dans ces
conditions sur les circonstances dans
lesquelles ils participent à une
interpellation à la fois le contexte
particulier de violence mais aussi le
contexte dans lequel il le fait je ne
reviens pas là non plus sur les propos
de la directrice de l'igpn sur la
caractérisation de ces deux
de ces faits mais enfin tout ce faisceau
d'indicés
quand une fois je compte tenu de ce que
je sais à l'époque et compte tenu de ce
que toutes les autorités qui sont bien
plus je dirais compétentes que moi en
matière d'ordre public est relative à
l'appréciation qu'on peut porter sur
elle n'ont pas mentionné que c'est que
si on intègre alors oui dans qu' il
aurait été à l'autorité hiérarchique je
vous ferai faire l'examen de ce que
signifie l'article 40 qui se faire de ma
part s'applique à tout agent public
donc s'ils s'appliquent à tout agent
public légitimement je considère que
compte tenu des agents publics qui ont
été saisis et préalablement le fait
qu'il ne mentionne pas ce point s'ajoute
au faisceau d indices que je mentionnais
précédemment et m'amène à considérer que
à l'époque je n'ai vraiment aucune
raison de douter que la sanction est
proportionnée et je pense que
aujourd'hui encore encore une fois
compte tenu des éléments connus à
l'époque elle l'était je reviens
troisièmement sur votre question sur la
sanction
sur ce point j'insiste sur le fait que
la sanction et c'était la volonté du
directeur du cabinet mais je devrais
dire c'était notre volonté notre volonté
collective je suis parfaitement que la
sanction soit très rapide parce que il
est important quand fois il y avait une
faute et c'est une faute
à ne pas négliger foot en général la
sanction était très rapide mais sont
exécutés très lent et si nous en croyons
cela dit hier de bernières de cabinet
quand j'ajoute un point également
important pour pas qu'il y ait de
malentendu
sans revenir mais je pense que malgré
tout il est important de relever que le
directeur général de la police nationale
a dit lui-même que placer dans des
circonstances équivalente il aurait
probablement pris la même décision
et s'agissant de la question de la
retenue sur salaire effectivement comme
vous disiez tout à l'heure ce mini s'il
ya une question de l'appréciation
continue du statut contractuel de la
personne de l'application décret de 1986
et de la possibilité dans le cadre d'une
suspension de m d'appliquer une
suspension de salaires et en réalité au
moment de d'opérer la retenue sur
salaire cette question a surgi et cette
question est apparu comme pouvant
fragiliser la décision sa robustesse
juridique et escande être de pouvoir
être contestées et donc il a été
privilégiée par personne compétente de
privilégier une une retenue sur son jour
de congé mais à la fin l'objectif est
bien atteint la loi a été respectée
la sanction est complète
elle est définitive elle est du même
effet et
c'est ce qui me semble être le point
important je suis d'accord avec vous sur
leur corps à porter que cette question
d'une façon générale cette question
mérite peut-être une étude juridique et
encore une fois si ça leur laisse pas
cette option mais ça relève de mes
responsabilités vous avez des séries si
j'ai des services et du coup je pense
que pour l'avenir ça fait partie des
sujets qui est probablement en présence
d'un public utile d'aborder de façon à
ce que la procédure soit la plus robuste
possible et que on est immédiatement des
bons réflexes pour faire exactement
comme il faut endroit pour s'assurer que
on est des décisions qui soient
effectives robuste non contestable et à
la fin efficace puisque c'est ça qui
compte
et puis le dernier point vous avez
évoqué la participation de monsieur
vinolas différents événements je crois
que le directeur cabinet vous a répondu
hier je vous répondrai dans le même sens
effectivement trois événements le public
auquel tu voudras a eu l'occasion de
participer
ce sont trois événements qui présente me
semble-t-il la même caractéristique
d'être des événements d'une ampleur
exceptionnelle et d'être évidemment pas
pour le 14 juillet mais vous comprendrez
mon propos d'être non récurrents et qui
nécessite la mobilisation d'autres
entonnaient l'église oui la chefferie de
cabinet n'est pas un service qui est de
veto rick pléthorique et un événement un
événement vous voyez mes baisers comme
un événement comme l'organisation de
l'arrivée de l'équipe de france
l'accueil au palais de l'elysée 2
je crois de 1000 invités pour mille 3000
invités tout cas plusieurs milliers
d'invités des enfants des jeunes
accueillir une logistique considérable
non ça ne dépend pas d'une personne mais
je crois pouvoir vous dire que ce jour
là tout le monde est sur le pont
le chef de cabinet monsieur le chef
adjoint du cabinet
les personnes qui sont qui travaille à
la chefferie que ce soit monsieur
benalla ou où la personne qui qui avait
le même le même grade que lui au sein de
la chefferie et toute la chefferie et
j'ai tous les personnels du camp de
manik je peux vous dire que j'ai pu voir
de mon bureau l'ampleur de préparatifs
c'était une manifestation d'ampleur
exceptionnelle je sais pas si certains
d'entre vous ont pu assister
pareillement à la cérémonie d'entre eux
au point car ce sont des événements et
la pression et la réalisation de ces
événements en particulier quand se
déroulent à la présidence de la
république elle incombe à la présidence
de la république
effectivement il ya d'autres services
dans l'état mais la personne ultime ans
responsable ça reste la présidence de la
république s'il y un problème si
l'accueil mais est mal fait s'il ya des
débordements dans le palais de l'elysée
le jour où l'équipe de france est
accueillie là ce sera la responsabilité
de la présence d'un public dont je n'ai
aucun état d'âme à dire que dans des
circonstances comme celles ci il faut
que tout le monde puisse contribuer que
tout le monde puisse travailler
et j'ajoute une points supplémentaires à
la présidence de la république
je peux vous dire que les gens ne
ménagent pas leur peine et que les gens
qui travaillent à la chefferie de
cabinet ce sont des gens qui ont un
travail considérable c'est un travail
très dur et j'ajouterai que moi compris
toutes les personnes qui travaillent à
présidence de la république
le présent la république est une
personne je pense que vous le savez les
français ça c'est une personne très
exigeante avec lui même et avec les
autres
moi même je crois pas dire que je
travaille un petit peu et j'attends
effectivement que les collaborateurs de
l'engagement de
et je pense que c'était vrai sous sous
sous d'autres d'autre mandat
les personnes très de la présente année
il travaille énormément et quand il y à
des événements exceptionnels je peux
vous dire que tout le monde y contribue
bien monsieur le président sur vous avez
une courte questions à poser au
secrétaire général monsieur le
secrétaire général à ma qualité de
rapporteur de la budget des pouvoirs
publics je peux confirmer ce que vous
dites sur le travail considérable de
l'ensemble des personnels de la
présidence de la république est bien
entendu nous ne mettons nullement cela
en cause ma question est très simple
j'ai cette nuit eu l'occasion de
vérifier ce qu'avait évoqué notre
collègue françois pilé et il s'avère que
la l'article 11 de la loi du 11 octobre
2013 impose que l'ensemble des
collaborateurs qui figure au journal
officiel ou non remplissent une
déclaration d'intérêts et une
déclaration de patrimoine ce qui permet
en particulier permettrait de d'évoquer
les éventuels liens entre monsieur
benalla et des entreprises à caractère
privé de sécurité puisque cela n'a pas
été fait que c'est pas tant et puisqu'il
est patent que c'est nécessaire
quelle conclusion allez vous en tirez et
allez vous demander aux neuf personnes
qui sont aujourd'hui chargé de mission à
l'elysée et qui n'ont rempli
ni l'une ni l'autre de ces deux
déclarations de le faire monsieur le
souhaitez je nomme monsieur pilet qui
avait posé la question hier souhaite
compléter la question de notre reporter
oui merci monsieur le rapporteur d'avoir
repris ce thème puisque hier
effectivement notre commission
secrétaire général a appris avec une
certaine stupéfaction que des
collaborateurs du président de la
république n'avait pas au mépris des
dispositions claires je dis bien des
dispositions claires sur le secrétaire
général de la loi 2
2013 sur la transparence de la vie
publique n'avait pas déposé auprès de la
haute autorité pour la transparence de
la vie publique
leur déclaration de patrimoine et
surtout leurs déclarations d'intérêts
c'est le cas de monsieur benalla alors
pouvez-vous nous assurer que dans le cas
précis au moins maintenant pour monsieur
benalla cette déclaration va être
régularisé très rapidement puisque ce
nos missions constitue au surplus un
délit qui fait encourir trois ans
d'emprisonnement et 45000 euros d'amande
et dont l'existence l'existence de ce
délit est en raison du caractère public
de notre commission
désormais portée à la connaissance du
parquet de paris
c'est le secrétaire général merci
monsieur bazin c'est une question qui
évidemment relève l'organisation interne
la présence d'un public mais je n'ai ans
- j j'y répondrai lorsque le président
la république a été élu et lorsque j'ai
été nommé
lorsque les premiers collaborateurs
présents le public ont été nommés dont
le directeur de cabinet écossais
diplomatique et j'en passe j'ai posé la
question aux services de la présidence
de duchamp des personnes qui devaient
faire cette déclaration est à l'époque
il m'a été dit que la pratique à
l'elysée y compris pour la totalité du
mandat précédent avait été que les
déclarations d'intérêt ne sont ne sont
faites que par
les conseillers nommés au journal
officiel nous avons ni plus ni moins
poursuivi cette pratique ayant pris
connaissance de votre échange le hier
j'ai reposé la question
la même réponse n'a été fait s'agissant
de la pratique antérieure
je veux pas entrer dans ce débat j'ai
demandé aux services de me dire de façon
très claire ce qu'il en est et c'est ce
qui m'a répondu j'aurais l'occasion de
vérifier de façon plus améliorée je vais
bien au congo je je je mentionnais
effectivement en tout cas c'est ce qui
nous a été dit donc on s'est inscrit
dans cette pratique là et donc tous les
collaborateurs inscrits au journal
officiel
on fait des déclarations ce qui n'était
pas d'un procédé du reste on m'a dit
qu'il avait eu des échanges en son temps
avec la haute autorité sur ce sur ce
point je n'en ai pas je ne les ai pas vu
donc je t'en faire étape plus que plus
que cela indépendamment de cela puisque
vous avez abordé la question hier j'ai
moi-même fait que diligence et donc
effectivement nuit porte conseil mais le
secrétaire général du gouvernement
également
donc je le faisais de la question et il
m'a indiqué que son interprétation à la
lumière des débats parlementaires était
qu' il serait logique de les inclure et
du coup de façon à éviter tout tout
malentendu je demandais ce que les
services adresse
hier un message aux intéressés afin qu'
il puisse régulariser l'offre d'une part
que la situation puisse être clarifiées
sur le plan du droit je vais pas
demander de notes écrites ou squattage
gouvernement de fait si j'ai toute
confiance en son avis et ensuite que la
situation des intéressés puissent être
régularisés et du coup il leur a été
demandé hier de prendre contact je pense
qu'ils feront dans les meilleurs délais
en tout état de cause s'agissant des
désormais
8 nous avons lutté hui chargé de mission
dont deux qui sont dans les dents les
services de la présidence pour
lesquelles je ne sais pas des regrets si
le principe s'applique au regard de la
définition d'un collaborateur présent la
république enfin on clarifiera cela mais
était demandé la seconde qu'elle n'y a
pas de doute de régulariser leur
situation
j'en ai déjà deux puisqu'il y avait la
question il faut remercie monsieur le
secrétaire général en effet c'est la
preuve que nos travaux sont déjà utile
l'amélioration du fonctionnement de la
présidence de la république
de sorte que les mauvaises pratiques de
l'ancien monde ne déborde pas trop sur
les nouvelles pratiques du nouveau monde
alors mes chers collègues maintenant
nous avons les questions de chacune et
chacun d'entre vous je vous rappelle la
règle que nous avons accepté une minute
pas plus pour la question si possible -
et donc je donne dans la parole à
monsieur py les faits président
effectivement j'avais deux questions ma
première intervention a permis de
préciser celle du rapporteur et
d'obtenir une réponse ce qui sur le fond
me satisfait dès lors qu'au surplus
j'espère que nous aurons la déclaration
d'intérêts de monsieur bénard avant la
fin de nos travaux la deuxième question
est très précise combien de conseillers
à l'elysée
ont-ils un contrat de travail et une
fiche de poste faisant référence à des
missions concernant directement ou
indirectement la sécurité du président
et pouvez-vous alors nous donner leurs
noms
monsieur le secrétaire général
je je je suis désolé je je devrais vous
revenir par écrit je ne je ne sais pas
le nombre de je ne pourrais pas vous
dire le nombre de personnes qui dans
leur contrat de travail ont la mention
de mai dès lors le secrétaire général
que vous vous engagez à répondre par
écrit à la question que j'ai posée je
suis satisfait en tout cas oui mais bien
je je je vais regarder comme je voulais
dit je ne gère pas moi même les contrats
de travail des collaborateurs de
l'elysée au général et des 822 je crois
tp de la présidence y compris quant aux
mentions spécifiques qui peuvent y est
mention je vous remercie nos murs je
pense que excusez moi pardon monsieur le
président je pense que la majorité
d'entre eux du reste n'ont pas de
contrat je pense que la majorité d'entre
eux s'agissant de fonctionnaires ne sont
pas dans une situation contractuelle
très honnêtement c'est pas aux
fonctionnaires que je fais allusion
c'est surtout aux contractuels du type
de monsieur benalla qui ont mon avis
nécessaire d'un contrat de travail écrit
et qui s'il n'y avait pas une fiche de
poste démontrerait l'existoire d'une
situation un peu curieuse mais je
regarderai ce point je veux je veux
vraiment je suis désolé je l' ai déjà
dit mais je veux vraiment insister sur
ce que je veux je veux surtout pas
laisser à penser ou aux membres de cette
commission ou à qui que ce soit qui nous
regarderait aujourd'hui que la sécurité
du président de la république
non non non je dis je saisis juste cette
occasion d vraiment qu'on leur ait
affirmé parce que vraiment je serais
surpris et choqué qu'on puisse laisser
penser à quiconque que la sécurité
présents dans le public serait assuré
par ' je ne sais quel est le vigile ou
agents privés et d'autres personnes que
les membres du commandement militaire ou
de jesper voilà mais je je je je saisis
cette occasion ce nous ce n'est pas une
réponse évidemment voter
merci monsieur le secrétaire général
monsieur colombard merci monsieur le
président monsieur secrétaire général
j'aimerais savoir depuis quand existe
le poste est la fonction occupée par
monsieur benalla quelle a été sa
rémunération en mai juin et avril et
quelle est la superficie exacte de
l'appartement qu'il occupe qu'est quai
branly
on sait ce qu ils ne sont pas venus
ouvrir savoir ce que c'est alors si vous
ne savez pas vous ne l'écrirai mais on
aimerait bien savoir que monsieur le
secrétaire général alors comme je pense
d'attaqué de la ville a déjà dit ce sont
des informations qui relève de
l'organisation interne la présenta
république ben la superficie oui
également mais je vais je vais revenir
sur ces sur sur ces points
je veux le budget et la gestion du
personnel la présence d'art publiques
sont gérées sous le contrôle de la cour
des comptes et vous trouverez beaucoup
d'informations et r général d'accor l'a
simplement vous laisse vous rendez vous
répondez pas c'est bien mais je vous
réponds je ne vous non je ne vais pas
communiqué les superficies des
appartements du palais de l'alma du
reste je n'ai pas avec moi le catalogue
et la cartographie des appartements avec
avec leur métrage
je ne vais pas communiqué les salaires
des personnes qui travaillent à la
présidence de la république
on n'a en revanche pas ce que c'était
important vous avez si le sens
d'ailleurs ça c'est la raison de ce
point de vue je pense de votre question
me face aux hommes de rumeurs puisque
monsieur benalla n'a pas occupé
effectivement de logements
à la résidence de l'alma jamais occupé
donc à la réponse à votre question quel
métrage de l'appartement qu'il occupe et
la réponse et il n'a pas occupé de
l'appartement semble-t-il
nous avons effectivement démenti une
rumeur quant au niveau de son salaire
parce qu'elle était chargée de mission
il n'a pas le niveau de 10000 euros dont
j'ai pu entendre parler il ya toute une
série d'autres rumeurs auxquelles le
présent de lui même a tenu à tous j'ai
vu qu'un quotidien avait d'ailleurs
publié l'intégralité d'un propos qu'il a
tenus dans un dans un cadre privé dans
lequel il répond aussi à la question de
il aurait été de 12 vers patrice randall
là aussi d'y proposer comme sous préfet
ce qui est totalement fantaisiste qu'on
envisageait de le nommer peut-être
j'espère ce qui est tout aussi
fantaisiste et et ainsi de suite donc et
pour répondre à votre question sur
depuis quand existe et 7,7 cette
fonction des veut dire dès l'origine je
pense mais je jeu là aussi je
préférerais pouvoir regarder ça de plus
près je pense que le saouler quinquennat
précédent le des fonctions équivalentes
existe et il m'a semblé d'ailleurs avoir
entendu à une audition hier ou
avant-hier quelqu'un évoquant des
fonctions sous le quinquennat précédent
qui me semblait être bien y avoir conclu
par deux sens de cette décision de la
date de cette décision de la date de son
embauche certainement date de la
création du poste avec cette fonction
particulière cc c'est très certainement
dans les semaines qui ont suivi le
l'élection et l'installation du nouveau
cabinet le directeur de cabinet du
président de république à qui nous avons
posé cette question s'est engagé hier à
nous faire parvenir les documents qui
touche le statut personnel de monsieur
benalla et je confirmerai cette demande
merci chers collègues de votre question
monsieur bonnecarrère whip monsieur le
président mes chers collègues
monsieur ce qu est un général deux
questions dans le prolongement de
l'introduction très structuré de notre
président première question pouvez vous
monsieur le secrétaire général nous
préciser le statut de la présidence de
la république nous le clarifier vous
avez plusieurs reprises dans votre
intervention parler de la présidence de
la république vous nous avez parlé d'une
assez grande maison plus de 800
personnes il ya quelques secondes nous
avait dit 922 tp je connais 15 article
dans la constitution 5 à 19 sur le
statut du président de la république est
ce que la notion de présidence de la
république c'est une formule un peu
fictive qui définit la relation avec le
président de la république ou est ce
qu'avec le temps avec un budget il ya
une sorte d'entité public présidence de
la république qui s'est constituée
qu'elle est née finalement le statut
quand serait de quelles en seraient les
règles et deuxième question qui a la
responsabilité de trier classer et
hiérarchiser l'information informé en
président de la république quelle que
soit sa puissance évidente de travail
est un exercice forcément complexes
notamment lorsqu'il se trouve à en
australie qui a cette responsabilité de
hiérarchiser l'information de
hiérarchiser les éléments à arbitrer
est-ce que c'est typiquement le rôle du
secrétaire un des rôles du secrétaire
général
où est ce que cette le rôle du directeur
de cabinet
merci monsieur le secrétaire général
lors de cette deuxième réponse je vous
réponds très simplement et très
directement c'est évidemment de ma
responsabilité de hiérarchiser
l'information d'être une sorte de
je veux dire de gare de triage tout ce
qui vient mais j'ajouterais c'est de la
responsabilité de tous chacun à son
niveau à cette responsabilité-là vous
imaginez que le flux d'informations qui
remonte à la présidence de la république
bonne journée dieu merci tout n'arrive
pas dans mon bureau
heureusement et dieu merci je ne suis
pas le seul point d'entrée de toutes les
informations qui arrivent à la
présidence de la république parce que je
crois que une vie n'y suffiraient pas et
donc chacun à son niveau et
destinataires d'information qui viennent
de l'extérieur et chacun à son niveau
fait exactement ce même trio que fait
référence et chacun décide ce qui relève
de ses responsabilités en réfère à ses
archives
lorsque cette personne juge nécessaire
et ainsi de suite jusqu'à jusqu'au
secrétaire général à charge pour moi de
d'informer le président la république
des éléments dont je pense qu'il est
pertinent soit porté à sa connaissance
ou de lait de les prendre sur moi
a fortiori quand il est à dix mille
kilomètres et que j'imaginais je ne peux
pas départ des façons de trop trop
détaillée et j'ajoute un point le
président de la république et je le dis
parce que il a eu l'occasion de
s'exprimer sur ce sujet je pense est un
point important est très attaché à ce
que chacun à son niveau
exerce ses responsabilités c'est pas
quelqu'un qui se qui se défausse
c'est quelqu'un qui fait confiance et
qui attend que j'incarne fois chacun son
niveau chacun prenne ses responsabilités
et prennent des décisions qui incombe à
son niveau et qu'on ne soit pas dans une
logique dans laquelle pour toute
l'information qu'on reçoit chacun
remonte au niveau supérieur en disant
comme ça je vois pas de problème parce
que c'est important que chacun à ses
responsabilités je vous avouerai ci
dessus
pourtant pour moi parce que si personne
ne prenait aucune décision à quelque
niveau que ce soit la présence à un
public je serai rapidement submergé le
statut de la présidence de la république
vous l'avez dit un statut présent la
république a un statut constitutionnel
que vous connaissez la présidence de la
république mais comme l'autre évidemment
et une est une institution qui a un
statut un petit peu plus particulier
puisque comme vous le savez comme
c'était déjà relevé ne dispose pas d'un
corps de fonctionnaires les agents de la
présence de la république sont des
agents qui sont détachés mis à
disposition par d'autres administrations
il n'y a pas d'agent de la présidence de
la république en ce sens le dire la
présence de la public en tant que que le
corps se dire administratif n'existe pas
elle fonctionne par la mise à
disposition d'agents angle ça n'empêche
pas pour autant que son administration
soit structuré et comme le présent à
public
l'ady gil a souhaité que cette
organisation puisse puisse évoluer la
corse et de l'organisation interne de la
prison grappling je n'entrerai pas dans
les détails je me contenterai de vous
indiquer que c'est un exercice qui a été
engagé dès la fin de l'année dernière
parce que c'est une organisation que
connaît bien votre votre président jc
structuré on va dire par sédimentation
et sur laquelle je pense qu'il est utile
faire évoluer ce sont la rendre plus
lisible plus efficace
moins coûteuse également et ça n'empêche
pas l'exercice de contrôle j'ai fait
référence à françois la question du
sénateur collombat au contrôle de la
cour des comptes
il est évidemment contrôle que vous
connaissez bien quel camp portera
faisait la force tout à l'heure qu'il
contrôle le parlementaire dans le cadre
des lois de finances et de la mission
sur les pouvoirs publics c'est le
président caennais
merci monsieur le président mais je
perds général le général de gaulle
disait du secrétaire-général de cette
fonction le secrétaire général de
l'elysée est au centre est au courant de
tout phrase qui est restée célèbre
vous êtes à la tête d'une équipe de 50
collaborateurs 39 conseillers techniques
11 rattaché à la présence de la
république tchèque 3 questions très
rapide
combien de chargé de mission vous y avez
répondu mais combien ont-ils de
responsabilité importante je pense en
particulier aux postes stratégiques de
chargé de mission auprès du chef d'état
major du président occupé par un certain
monsieur ludovic que chaker
saviez-vous deuxième question que chacun
avait supervisé le recrutement de
monsieur ben alla comme directeur de la
sécurité du candidat d'emmanuel macron
troisième question est-il du visage
monsieur le ster général au sein du
cabinet du président de la république de
doublonner toutes les fonctions
officielles par des personnes qui
seraient proches et qui recueillerait
toute la confiance du chef de l'état le
chef de l'état a utilisé le mot de
trahison donc trahison c'est pour un
homme de confiance donc il y à des
hommes et des femmes de confiance au
sein de l'elysée pouvez-vous nous
répondent en la matière un dernier mot
en termes d'information monsieur
président bat pour vous dire que
monsieur benalla vient de donner une
interview très longue au journal le
monde ce qui me conforte dans l'idée de
pouvoir entendre monsieur benalla au
sein de notre commission denquête merci
chers collègues initiale sur est un
général
ce alors même interrogé sur le nombre de
deux chargés de mission sont rattachés
de chargés de mission il y as est chargé
de mission enfin en ce compris alexandre
benalla qui ne l'est plus changé de
mission ce qu'ils étaient licenciés qui
sont
rattaché e
ou à des à des conseillers techniques et
donc qui travaillent au sein du cabinet
du président de la république
ce sont tous des changes des missions
qui sont vraiment
qui sont rattachés à des conseillers
techniques et 100
mais connaître leur leurs
responsabilités et
je les connais tous évidemment
personnellement ce sont des gens
remarquables et qui travaille énormément
je crois pouvoir dire que il est logique
qu'il soit chargé de mission regard des
responsabilités qu'ils font ils ne
s'occupent pas des postes de chefs de
pôles ou des responsabilités de
direction ou de ou avec des
responsabilités particulières
vous avez m'interroger sur le cas de
ludovic shaker qui sauf erreur de ma
part et chargé de mission auprès de
l'état-major particulier car c'est un
militaire me semble-t-il
ou en tout cas où réservistes et
[Musique]
et donc il est il est rattaché à
l'état-major particulier on avait
interrogé sur les circonstances de
l'embauché de monsieur benalla au sein
au sein de la campagne au sein du
mouvement sur lequel pour tout vous dire
je ne je ne sais pas exactement à quelle
date il a été il était recruté
il est possible effectivement que
ludovic shaker et jouer un rôle dans ce
recrutement puisque ludovic chez care a
fait partie des premiers salariés du
mouvement en marche
je vous le confirme et j'ai connu du
reste alexandre benalla au sein du
mouvement en marche une fois qu'il avait
rejoints mais je joue je ne sais pas
quelle date était alors je vous confirme
enfin réponse à votre dernière question
que il y a beaucoup de personnes qui
rentreraient dans les définitions vous
avez donné me semble-t-il
en terme de confiance par construction
je pense que j'ose espérer que votre
serviteur comme les membres du cabinet
président la république ont la confiance
du président de la république
comme je disais tout à l'heure c'est
pour moi c'est ça pique bien évidemment
à moi je pense la reconstruction au
présent implique qu'un principe de quand
on a la responsabilité d'une d'une
administration d'une équipe quelle
qu'elle soit on doit faire confiance à
ses collaborateurs et la confiance est
un principe clair de recrutement
si on n'a pas confiance dans ses
collaborateurs je pense que il vaut
mieux changer
et j'ajouterai que les dix youn et je
leur dis parce que je considère que
c'est quelqu'un qui a un sens de l'état
exceptionnelle et c'est encore plus vrai
qu'entre le collaborateur en question
s'appelle patrick strzoda comme ce
qu'est né à vous d'y réagir
oui vraiment très rapidement monsieur le
président mais bien sûr qu'il faut des
hommes et des femmes de confiance auprès
du président sinon ça ne pouvait pas
marcher
j'ai été ministre et j'ai la même le
même principe c'est la question du
dédoublonnage de certaines fonctions par
des personnes qui ne relève pas votre
anciennement dante et du cadre cette
secrétaire général vous vouliez ajouté
non je je je je je n'ai pas le sentiment
aux ministres qu'il est qu'il ait le
moindre
dédoublonnage et les chargés de missions
qui sont kg président de la république
exerce chacun des démissions dont je
crois pour des jeux les identifie
parfaitement qui doublonnent en rien mes
fonctions administratives a fortiori à
fortiori du du gouvernement je suis très
attaché à ce que l'indiqué même jeu
présent à chacun reste à sa place la
présence d'un flic ça n'est pas une lan
la présidence de la république ce n'est
pas le gouvernement en effet vous
faisons pas dire non monsieur monsieur
le secrétaire général je crois qu'il
faut être clair le comportement et ça se
voit de monsieur mais dallas est très
proche de celui d'un garde du corps de
quelqu'un qui exerce une mission de
protection et de sécurité
alors je crois que monsieur kader est
fondée lorsqu'il dit qu'il y à phénomène
de doublons et finalement de
d'imprécisions et de confusion adam
jourdain
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
sécrétaire général toujours dans cette
veine et dans cette idée de confusion
dont nous avait d'ailleurs à demi mot
dit tout à l'heure quelles peuvent être
effectivement accrédité par le fait que
monsieur v dallas avait eu des fonctions
de garde rapprochée auprès du candidat
emmanuel macron et de ce fait il a
peut-être pensé qu'il pouvait les
continuer quand j'ai sous les yeux ici
l'arrêté de port d'armes de monsieur
benalla dans lequel il est indiqué
clairement dans les considérant que ce
port d'armes est autorisée du fait que
monsieur b dallas est chargé d'une
mission de police
alors ça n'est pas tout à fait ce que
vous nous indiquez lorsque vous parlez
des fonctions de monsieur benalla mais
il est chargé d'une mission de police
dans le cas de son action de
coordination de la sécurité de la
présidence de la république
est ce que tout ça n'est pas un peu
contradictoire avec les propos que vous
tenez sur la réalité de ce que seraient
des fonctions de monsieur ménard y avoir
de définition de fonctions de monsieur
pénale à celle qui fait l'objet d'une
sorte de note de service interne et
celle qui est exposé à la préfecture de
police pour obtenir le port d'armes
quand le prophète police autorise le
port d'armes et motive son autorisation
par d'une part une fonction de police
d'autre part une fonction d'organisation
de la sécurité ne voyons pas ça dans la
description des fonctions qui nous a été
faite par vous même comme par le
directeur de cabinet hier
comme je vous l'aï dit tout à l'heure je
ne pas connaître des modalités d'octroi
du du port d'armes de monsieur de
monsieur benalla donc je ne veux pas
vous répondre de manière aussi aussi
détaillé collection de bena la 107 cette
question et
et je n'ai rien à rien a ajouté je ne
pourrai ce que vous rappeler ce que les
autorités compétentes nous ont répondu
c'est à dire en particulier enfin vous
n'avez pas entendu le préfet de police
je crois si vous entendez donc je pense
que c'est l'autorité de de délivrance et
patrick strzoda vous avez vous a répondu
sur ce point je n'ai vraiment rien à
ajouter non monsieur sueur monsieur le
secrétaire général il y à là quelque
chose de grave est que nous ne pouvons
pas laisser dans cet état
l'arrêté dit considérant que monsieur
benalla est chargé d'une mission de
police ce qui est contradictoire avec ce
qui nous est dit par ailleurs
[Musique]
merci monsieur le secrétaire général
madame eustache brinio merci monsieur le
président monsieur le secrétaire général
vous êtes revenu lors des buts vos
propos sur les événements du 1er mai
pour lequel on a certain nombre
d'informations et peut-être c'est plus
lisible
aujourd'hui pour nous est revenu sur le
rôle du j espère il ya quelques instants
vous nous avez précisé que dans la
l'organisation de la venue des bleus sur
les champs elysées tout le monde avait
sa place si j'avais cru quoi j'ai cru
comprendre que monsieur bennett a été un
pion essentiel dans la sécurisation de
la venue des bleus sur les champs ça
m'interroge moi je vais revenir sur
quelque chose qui pour moi me semble
extrêmement important et je pense que
les français ont besoin de réponses dans
cette affaire dite benalla parce
qu'aujourd'hui ils n'en ont pas et moi
je n'en ai pas je ne sais pas exactement
aujourd'hui qu'elles sont ou quelles
étaient les missions et les fonctions
précises de monsieur benalla à l'elysée
qu'elle était vraiment parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a des réponses très
évasif sur ses fonctions et ses missions
voilà à quoi servait-il et puis on peut
légitimement se poser la question y
at-il entre guillemets d'autres benalla
à l'élysée pour le cas les rôles
seraient très floue avec une espèce
d'organisation un peu parallèle en tout
cas les français aujourd'hui peuvent
légitimement se poser la question comme
nous les élus nous pouvons nous poser la
question est ce le secrétaire général
monsieur le secrétaire général c'est le
voka merci madame la sénatrice
je pense que le directeur de cabinet
vous avez vous a indiqué hier qu'elle
était les fonctions de monsieur benalla
qui était donc dans l'équipe de la chef
de cabinet et comme je vous l'indiquais
tout à l'heure qui est une équipe qui
est chargé de coordonner l'action des
autres services
c'est à dire que ce sont des missions
d'organisation et de coordination
à cet égard je ne vous ai pas dit qu
alexandre benalla avait la
responsabilité de la sécurisation de
l'arrivée de l'équipe de france cette
responsabilité a fortiori sur la voie
publique et les de la spécialité du
préfet de police
avec sandrine là n'a rien à voir avec
l'organisation du dispositif de sécurité
sur les champs elysées rien à voir
bon oui parce que pour des questions de
logistique et d'organisation puisque à
la fin
ce ce car je ne fais que vous faire la
pause 2-2 de bon sens je ne définit pas
la présence à blick le trajet de
des cars même lorsque ils convoient
l'équipe de france championne du monde
mais à la fin ce quart est attendue la
présence de la république
ce sont des circonstances qui sont
évidemment très particulière il ya
énormément de monde et donc dans ce
cadre il a vocation à avoir une
interaction avec des services extérieurs
à présent à un public y compris des
services de police et à commencer par la
préfecture de police
mais même que si la chefferie de cabinet
en charge l'organisation des événements
en lien également avec les encore une
fois c'était une mission de coordination
si elle n'a pas de de relations de
discussion avec avec les services de
l'état compétents
je lui reprocherais parce que le chef de
cabinet et son équipe
lorsque il y un déplacement du président
de la république dans votre département
il a évidemment des discussions avec le
préfet de ce département
il a évidemment des discussions avec les
services de la préfecture avec les
équipes de police de ce département et
je lui reprocherait de ne pas le faire
ça fait partie de sa mission
ça ne veut pas dire pour autant que la
chefferie de cabinet quand bien même est
doté de membres du corps préfectoral si
j'ose dire devrait se substituer aux
préfets des départements ce qui là
serait une faute
chacun doit rester à sa place mais c'est
une mission de coordination
d'organisations et qui suppose
effectivement des liens avec l'extérieur
et alexandre benalla il exercer cette
mission pour à la fois pour des
déplacements sur des déplacements
officiels du du président de la
république majoritairement sur le
territoire national et des déplacements
non officiel du
le président la république entendre des
déplacements privés s'il ad'autres
alexandre benalla non je ne suis pas sûr
de se dire tout à fait le sens de votre
question mais je vais je jeu mais je je
je vénère moi mes forces et lui d'y
répondre sur ce il y a évidemment
d'autres personnes au sein de la
présidence de la république qui exerce
des missions similaires
il est évident que on ne peut on ne
pourrait pas fonctionner sans
précisément une chefferie bien dotées et
y compris quelqu'un qui prend en charge
les missions que monsieur la prenait
jusqu'à jusqu'à récemment
donc du point de vue du fonctionnement
de la présence d'un public je vous
confirme que il faut bien que il y est
mais quelqu'un qui exerce ses missions
qantas il yad'autres là aussi ceux
d'autres personnes qui auraient commis
des actes identiques très franchement
j'espère que non et si c'est le cas je
ne le sais pas et si on a deux qui sont
susceptibles de l'être je vais la porte
la même réponse
j'espère que non et je hais je peux je
puis vous dire que le personnel de lisea
des consignes très très stricte en
matière de ce qu'on attend d'eux en
terme de comportement
monsieur secrétaire général je prolonge
la question mais vous n'avez peut-être
pas encore eu le temps de remplacer
monsieur benalla comptez-vous faire en
sorte que son successeur est également
un permis de port d'armes
pour être très franc à ce stade son
poste a été n'a pas été n'a pas été
remplacé les équipes ce qui explique
d'ailleurs que lors des événements en
fait les équipes la chefferie de cabinet
est un petit peu et était sous sous
tension est ce qui explique que du coup
il induit
il a dû y contribuer et quant à la
question du pardon je pense ça dépendra
évidemment du profil de l'intéressé
typiquement aujourd'hui la chaufferie de
cabinet est plutôt des profils de nature
préfectoral je ne crois pas qu'ils aient
de port d'armes
je vous remercie madame jourda merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
secrétaire général dans la continuité
aussi de cette question dont j'aimerais
bien comprendre la réponse vous nous
indiquer qu'il ya des gens qui ont une
mission similaire aujourd'hui similaire
à celle de monsieur benalla d'accord
donc qui est lié à la coordination de la
sécurité
[Musique]
je vous en prie je vous en prie non
c'est pas une mission de coordination de
la sécurité d'une mission de
coordination de tous qui doit tout ce
qui contribue à au cas d'espèce
l'organisation d'un déplacement du
président de la république
la sécurité c'est une dimension il ya
beaucoup d'autres dimensions d'entre
vous qui ont eu des responsabilités
ministérielles tout ministre à un
cabinet à un chef de cabinet et ce chef
de cabinet est responsable de ça et va
coordonner les sujets de sécurité
les sujets de communication les sujets
de de relations presse
les sujets de de relation avec vous
j'insiste sur ce point j'aurais dû le
dire plutôt parce qu'évidemment dans un
déplacement un élément majeur et la
relation avec les élus
alors nous ne sommes pas d'accord sur
les propos puisque moi je reprenais en
réalité ce qui était dans l'arrêté de
police assure la coordination de la
sécurité
ils ont une mission similaire donc que
nous ne finirons pas ont-ils également
un port d'armes en ont-ils mais ils
parlent ensemble moi je il a à ma
connaissance non à ma connaissance non
mais ce sont je pense qu'ils sont
essentiellement fonctionnaires et
membres du corps préfectoral
je ne crois pas qu à titre privé de deux
ports d'armes pas non non comprenez
monsieur le secrétaire général nous
faisons ces questions peut-être vous par
estelle soit maladroite soit vous ne
comprenez pas le but
moi je vous le dis le but il y a une
définition de fonction qui nous a été
décrite par vous même et le directeur de
cabinet du président de la république et
il ya une définition de fonction qui
figure dans l'arrêté du préfet de police
attribuant un port d'armes
une autorisation de port d'armes
monsieur mais dallas et qui dit
considérant précieux benalla est chargé
d'une mission de police dans le cadre de
son action de coordination de la
sécurité de la présidence de la
république avec les forces militaires et
j'espère je dois considérer à vous
entendre qu'il faut retenir votre propre
définition de la fonction de monsieur
banana et non pas celle qui a été
communiquée au préfet de police pour
obtenir le port d'armes c'est juste ça
je crois que c'est ça la la la
conclusion qu'on peut en tirer
mais le monsieur de secrétaire général
je pensais aussi une mission de
coordination ce qu' il y a il ya
différentes missions fonctions à
coordonner dans un déplacement
la relation avec les élus la relation
avec la presse les enjeux de
communication d'eon de décoder à
l'intérieur de chacun de ces domaines y
compris la sécurité il peut y avoir
plusieurs services de sécurité qui sont
concernés il
vous allez dans un département ya gspr
il ya le les services de sécurité locaux
la police la gendarmerie que sage de ce
point de vue là il peut y avoir une
mission de coordination de la sécurité
mais en revanche ils n'assurent pas la
sécurité du président je veux pas qu'ils
aient de l'ambiguïté d'ambiguïté là
dessus monsieur sur monsieur monsieur le
secrétaire général je pense que la douce
sommes devant quelque chose qui a
beaucoup d'importance parce que les
termes de l'arrêté que viens de relire
le président philippe bas montre que le
port d'armes a été dévolue par le
ministère de l'intérieur sur demande je
suppose de l'hélice et ce à la
préfecture de police et le ministère de
l'intérieur la police est partie du
ministre de l'intérieur sur la base
d'une définition de la coordination
entre une tâche de police et une tâche
que police je m'excuse quand on relit la
phrase il s'agit absolument pas de la
coordination est les préfectures la
presse etc
les différents services engagés par un
déplacement présidentiel
à ce stade nous prenons acte de cette
contradiction
je crois que ce n'est pas la peine
d'aller plus loin
il ya un certain nombre d'éléments que
nous avions déjà recueilli qui vont dans
le sens d'une appréciation d'un
fonctions de monsieur benalla comme une
fonction de sécurité
les vétérinaires le directeur de cabinet
ne dis ça n'est pas une fonction de
sécurité le préfet de police prend une
décision parce qu'on lui a indiqué que
c'était une fonction de sécurité
voilà où nous en sommes sur ce point et
à chacun de se faire un jugement sur la
réalité de la fonction de monsieur ben
alla à partir de quelques indices que
nous avons pu obtenir alors nous allons
des indices qui sont des faits ces
indices ne sont dit ce sont des faits
des as distinction bien sûr pour
caractéristique d'être contradictoire je
m'excuse je veux que ceci soit dit et
entendu et je n'ai pas le sentiment
d'avoir dit autre chose que ce que vous
venez de vous dire d'autre
je vous en donne acte monsieur le
président à sion alors je vous remercie
madame benbassa vous souhaitiez je crois
poser une question oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le secrétaire général
il y à une mise à pied à l'endroit de
monsieur banal en début mai c'est donc
une sanction vous faire pour le
connaissez vous c'est vous même qui
avait parlé d'une faute je ne savais pas
jusque là que la sanction appelée
récompense je lis sur le fac similé de
la déclaration qu'a fait monsieur
benalla auprès de l'administration
fiscale
attestant son changement d'un dress ce
changement d adresse qui prend effet le
9 juillet indique 11 quai branly j'ai
donc il ya quand même un problème n'est
ce pas il a été récompensé il a eu son
appartement on ce quai branly puisque il
fait un changement d'avis
deuxièmement je voudrais faire une
rectification quand même il ya j'ai posé
la question sur la suspension du
traitement de monsieur benalla et votre
votre collègue monsieur tron a répondu
que les 15 jours de suspension feront
l'objet d'une retenue sur les droits à
congés qu'ils avaient en reliquat au
titre de l'année 2010 est pourtant il me
semble que les tests les textes
applicables sont claires j'ai fait
vérifier
je cite un congé non pris ne donne pas
lieu à ne donne lieu à aucune indemnité
compensatrice
comment monsieur benalla peut-il ainsi
percevoir une indemnité compensatrice
pour des congés non payés
je vous donne une petite indication au
cas où ils seraient licenciés pour faute
lorsqu'on est licencié pour faute un
contractuel public
enfin lorsqu'on contractuels et
licencié cela n'ouvre pas normalement
droit au versement ni d'une indemnité de
licenciement ni même à une indemnité
compensatrice de congés annuels est ce
que monsieur benalla a été licencié pour
faute maintenant l'espoir et de telles
indemnités lyon elle était versée
malgré cela mais merci c'est une
question très précise monsieur de ce
qu'est très nuageux mais il ya deux
questions il y en a une sur le sur le
logement et une sur sur le licenciement
enfin sur la sur la sanction alors comme
jeu comme je vous le disais dans mon
propos enfin dans leurs pensées
les premières questions je ne
la gestion interne du personnel de
l'elysée relève de la responsabilité du
dilatoire cabinet il me me rends compte
donc je ne cherche pas du tout l'esquivé
le moindre responsabilité mais je ne
suis pas intervenu
et je n'interviens pas dans
l'attribution des logements à la à la
résidence de
de l'alma eux
dont je crois d'ailleurs le la liste est
assez assez largement diffusé et qui est
qui en fait
accueil très majoritairement mais la
cour des comptes a déjà écrit
abondamment sur ce sur ce sujet des
personnes qui sont qui font l'objet
d'une nécessité absolue de de service
c'est-à-dire dont la des exigences de
disponibilité sont sont particulièrement
fortes
donc je ne suis pas intervenu dans
l'attribution du logement et donc je ne
reviendrai pas sur ce que le directeur
de cabinet a pu vous dire sur cette
question et fiscales qui atteste ce
changement mais le 9 juillet 2018
je j'entends bien je vous dis simplement
que je n'ai pas eu à connaître de
l'attribution de ce logement et de jeu
très franchement je ne je ne je ne
connais pas les détails de cette de
cette attribution
ah ben oui je vous le dis très
directement je ne m'occupe pas et très
franchement je pense que il est logique
encore une fois je reviens sur cette
question de hiérarchie des
responsabilités
je fais beaucoup de choses je peux vous
dire je travaille un petit peu mais je
ne m'occupe pas de l'attribution de tous
les logements
au sein de l'elysée fût ce à monsieur
benalla et donc je m'en voudrais nous
donner une information erronée sur ce
sujet qui ne serait qu'une information
rapportée ce sur l'effet sur la date la
taille de l'appartement où effectivement
et pour ce qui est de son delà de la
sanction
je reviendrai simplement sur la la
séquence qui est que au moment où la
section la sanction est prise on y lit
un avertissement avec pouvant conduire à
licenciement mais de la décision du
licenciement
elle n'est pas prise à ce moment là bien
évidemment donc on considère que la
sanction est appliquée pour des raisons
de sécurisation juridique sur lequel je
reviens pas lié au terme de deux
suspensions et les nécessités d'un
assurer la robustesse la retenue le
directeur salaires s'est révélé trop
fragile et du coup la sanction à la
retenue sur salaire la modalité de
retenue a pris la forme d'une annulation
quelque sorte qu'ils de retenue de jours
de congé et ce quand à son licenciement
oui c'est un cetain c'est à la suite
d'une nouvelle faute effectivement qu'il
a été qu'il a été licencié dans le cadre
juridique bien alors on amène bas ça il
faut que je donne la parole aux
collègues que chacun puisse poser sa
question
alors oui mais c'est ce n'est peut-être
pas une réponse que vous jugerez ou que
la commission jugera satisfaisante mais
c'est la réponse du secrétaire général à
nous et nous ne pouvons pas le forcer à
dire ce qui ne veut ou ne peut pas dire
mais nous souhaitons le monsieur de
secrétaire du drame
néanmoins relevé que moi je comprends
très bien cette idée que le patron ne
puisse pas prendre toutes les décisions
c'est pour ça que et à une équipe et on
doit déléguer de sorte que le bureau du
patron ne soit pas encombrer de
décisions qui sont multiples dans
l'ordinaire des jours de toute
organisation vus revus c'est du bon sens
de comprendre ça mais je sais aussi je
crois savoir que quand on occupe une
fonction de
numéro 1 dans une équipe et que quelque
chose qui était qui relevait de simples
décisions quotidiennes prend une très
grande importance politique
alors je crois monsieur le secrétaire
général que le moment est venu pour vous
de vérifier point parfois ceux qui vous
seraient apparus comme des détails et
encore trois semaines mais qui
aujourd'hui sont des éléments ennemis
boutabout qui ont tous de l'importance
pour expliquer une situation et nous
notre devoir justement c'est d'y voir
clair c'est pour ça que vous posons
toutes ces questions y compris des
questions qui peuvent paraître à ceux
qui nous écoutent le très ponctuelle sur
le droit applicable à la sanction
imposée à collaborateurs les conditions
dans lesquelles cette sanction est
exécuté parce que c'est vrai que si on
se met à la place des gens c'est quand
même surprenant qu'on est annoncée une
retenue sur salaire et que soudainement
à la faveur d'une commission d'une
audition de la commission des lois on
apprenne que la retenue sur salaire n'a
pas eu lieu parce qu'il y avait un
problème juridique qu'on va la faire
autrement madame benbassa nous dit mais
les modalités nouvelles qu'on a choisis
ne sont elles réellement régulière elle
aussi bon voilà on fait émerger des
choses que nous mêmes nous n'aurions pas
eu à l'esprit si les problèmes ne
s'était pas posée mais je crois que il
est temps de mettre le projecteur sur ce
qui est un élément de ceux de ce dossier
c'est notre rôle de le faire mais je
n'ai pas à m'en excuser
au nom des collègues je comprends que
madame benbassa et ne soit pas tout
totalement satisfait de cette année
féminisme je convaincs d'assad de votre
réponse monsieur de secrétaire général
et si vous pouviez apporter les
précisions ultérieures
nous avons vu tout à l'heure que
l'audition d'hier vous a été utile sont
d'autres aspects de la gestion du
personnel de la présidence de la
république ya une question juridique qui
est maintenant sur la place publique
pour l'exécution de cette sanction
à vous de nous répondre plus précisément
que vous avez pu le faire ce matin en
allant de manière plus approfondie
examiner ce problème
bon alors nous continuons avec
maintenant la question de monsieur
grosdidier une minute monsieur
grosdidier et nous en avons parlé
ensemble et je vais m'en tenir à mon
papier pour justement limité mais je
tiens à dire des choses essentielles
après plus de deux heures d'audition
passive alors il y a deux affaires
pénales à la première c'est son
comportement le 1er mai qu'il justifie
par l'article 73 du code de procédure
pénale arguant du caractère délinquants
des manifestants interpellés l'enquète
judiciaire le déterminant la deuxième
celle qui nous intéresse c'est
l'éventuel dysfonctionnements de nos
institutions touchant à la sécurité du
chef de l'état alors des syndicalistes
policiers ont parlé de barbouzes de
police parallèle et cela en rajoute en
tout cas au malaise des policiers qui
n'avaient pas besoin de ça or vous nous
donnez l'impression vous même ceux qui
vous ont précédés de partager des
éléments de langage pour occulter cet
aspect du dossier notamment pour cacher
le rôle que monsieur benalla pouvait
jouer en matière de sécurité
un peu l'impression d'être baladés tout
de même et à vous entendre il n'aurait
été que le gentil organisateur des
déplacements et c'est ce qui aurait
c'est ce qu'indique ray cette note
or ils venaient non pas d'une agence de
voyages mais de la sécurité privée
il n'avait d'ailleurs aucune autre
compétence ou référence qu'en cette
matière
ils étaient référencées au cnaps le
général d'usure et nous a dit d'avoir
rappelé dans la réserve de la
gendarmerie
justement en raison de son expertise en
matière de protection rapprochée il
était d'ailleurs en fonction omniprésent
à la préfecture de police y ont traite
je crois des problèmes de sécurité et
malgré l'opposition du service de
protection
vous avez vous même demandé au préfet de
police vous même l'elysée demandé au
préfet de police cette autorisation de
port d'armes et comme l'indiqué le
président on s'est arrêté fait exprès
c'est vous avez déjà débordés de 35
service
de sécurité totale contradiction avec la
note
vous écrivez donc il ya un des deux
documents qui dit pas la vérité
et quand les camps les faits corrobore
plus tôt l'arrêté que la note on peut
s'interroger sur la sincérité des propos
qui nous sont tenus je crois tu sais pas
chacun de faire son opinion
il ya quand même des vérités qui sont à
établir
vous nous dites qu'il pouvait
coordonnées des services de sécurité
mais nous sommes désolés c'est la
fonction d'un fonctionnaire d'autorité
souhait on est les policiers nous disent
que le coordonnateur se prenait
d'ailleurs le le plus souvent pour le
supérieur alors est-ce que vous pouvez
continuer à nous dire que monsieur ben
alla ne s'occupait pas de sécurité à
l'elysée
la soie là pourquoi avoir écrit le
contraire et pouvez-vous c'est le dit le
secrétaire général
on va vous répondre vous avez terminé
aucun contrat que monsieur le secrétaire
général quand vous avez la parole elle
est visée en charge de missions de
sécurité
merci chers collègues je suis désolé
mais il faut que vous respectiez le
temps de parole parce que les collègues
le font
oui mais alors allez je vous répondrais
très très brièvement parce que j'ai peu
de chose à ajouter par rapport à ce que
je vous ai déjà indiqué sur les
fonctions de 6,2 monsieur benalla juste
j'apporte juste une précision je n'ai
pas dit qu'il ne s'occupait pas de
sécurité j'ai dit qu'il n'était pas
responsable de la sécurité en
particulier par les responsables de ses
côtés du président évidemment il avait à
connaître de questions de sécurité et
toute personne qui travaille dans
l'équipe du chef de cabinet du président
de la république à s'occuper de
questions de sécurité ça me semble
logique est important
simplement je comme de ce point de vue
là le fait pour un agent
l'espèce a chargé de mission d'avoir une
compétence en matière de sécurité
tu lui vient de sa vie d'avant
compétences dont je comprends qu'elle a
été reconnue par la direction générale
la gendarmerie nationale pour moi n'est
pas un handicap bien au contraire c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle il
est très fréquent que ce soit des postes
qu'ils soient occupés par des membres du
corps préfectoral qui ont des
responsabilités éminentes comme en
matière de sécurité mais je ne je ne
vous répondrai pas sur le port d'armes
que doit n'avait pas abordé dans votre
question mais sur lequel je ne je ne je
ne reviendrai pas mais le fait que
monsieur vient et des compétences en
matière de sécurité ne me semble pas
bien au contraire constituer un handicap
à l'exercice des fonctions qui faisait
qu'il exerçait d'autant que comme je
voulais dit il a exercé des fonctions de
sécurité préalablement avant que le pour
autant je veux vraiment encore une fois
parce que je veux vraiment pas kidman
entendu sur cette question vous avez
cité faire de bar blues ou de près par
neil mai mais la sécurité le président
d'art public je le répète elle assurée
par le commandement militaire de du
palais et par lui j'espère et personne
d'autre il ya des gens qui s'appellent
je ne pense très franchement je ne pense
pas qu'il y ait des contractuels au sein
d une caisse est une question de
différentes qui est de nature statutaire
on peut être contractuels dans le temps
là on peut être agent public et
contractuels donc je ne pense pas que
commandement du commandant militaire du
palais j'espère mon sens essentiellement
constituée de policiers et de gendarmes
mais il ya plein de ya plein de vie
plein de contractuels mais je hais ce
que vous voulez bien me laisser une
petite chance de président et moi-même
la commission cher collègue l'agent
l'avait terminé monsieur prix or alors
je vous je vous remercie
je donne la parole à monsieur alain
richard le président commission denquête
elle doit conclure sur des fêtes
vérifier l écrit un rapport et quand on
écrit on sort d à peu près des
impressions et des allégations
nous cherchons pour apprécier ce qui a
été bien ou mal faire la présidence s'il
y a eu des confusions de fonction de la
part de monsieur benalla notamment avant
le 1er mai et s'il ya eu des abus le
fonctions par rapport aux fonctions qui
lui étaient attribués observé que a été
question par exemple d'une voiture de
police
le directeur de cabinet hier a expliqué
qu'il s'agissait d'une voiture adaptée
aux cortèges de la présidence donc ceci
est déjà un fait qui a été écarté
les syndicats et la personne leurs
auditions étaient très rapides nous ont
formulé des appréciations très
défavorable sur le comportement de
monsieur benalla aucune de ces
appréciations n'a été circonstancié et
fera donc avant le rapport qu'on essaye
d'en savoir plus pour savoir s'il ya eu
des dates des lieux où son comportement
effectif vérifiables a été discutable
bien moi je vais savoir auprès du
secrétaire général
si s'agissant des cadres le travail de
bella la première - est-ce que nous
pouvons avoir
est-ce que nous pouvons avoir
l'organigramme de la fonction chef de
cabinet et subordonnées avec les
définitions de fonction et s'il ya eu
des notes
précisons les instructions de travail
éventuellement la prévention de
débordement de mission est ce que ces
documents écrits ont été produits avant
le 1er mai dans cours de la vie de la
présidence est-ce que vous considéreriez
légitime que nous en ayons connaissance
et enfin si précisément un peu
d'incertitude peuvent rester sur ces
sujets est il dans vos intentions dans
la mission que vous a demandé le
président de la république de révision
de l'organisation dit m ordre alors on
est parent dont une dernière question il
a été fait mention de trois capes de
pluie de 19 mai dans lesquelles monsieur
benalla serait apparue dans
l'organisation la conduite d'une
manifestation importante de la
présidence de la république
pourra-t-il être vérifié s'il y en a eu
d'autres depuis le 19 mai ou non
je vous remercie de cette question chers
collègues je voudrais dire que mais tout
à l'heure le président kennel a évoqué
aussi monsieur benalla a cru bon de
faire une interview dans le journal le
monde qui paraît aujourd'hui
et puisque dans cherchons des faits et
que monsieur kaner souhaitent mieux
connaître la position personnelle de
monsieur benalla nous avons au moins
quelques indications lui-même fait état
de friction d'inimitié d'opposition et
il dit
j'emmerde est pas mal de monde c'est une
indication sur le climat de travail dans
la perception qu'on avait en tout cas
monsieur biennale à monsieur le
secrétaire général pour répondre aux
questions précises et à la tante de
documents qui nous permettront de juger
sur pièces des choses et d'avoir une
appréciation fondé de manière plus
précise monsieur le secrétaire général
alors je vais pourrait très rapidement
sur les sur les trois points je vais
bien évidemment regarder ci
des notes ont pu être d'organisation ont
pu être produites sur le point que
soulevait monsieur le ministre et dans
quelle mesure dans le cadre légal je
pourrais vous en vous en donner
connaissance sachant que c'est une
question qui relève de l'organisation
interne la présence dans le public et de
la chefferie de cabinet mais je sais une
question que je vais regarder puisque
vous vous vous me invités mais ce sur
lequel je permettent de réserver ma
réponse mais je peux vous assurer que je
vais la regarder avec attention
deuxièmement vous avez évoqué là aussi
dans c'est une question d'organisation
un terme et je vous réponds bien
volontiers sur les les conséquences à en
tirer du point de vue de l'organisation
je peux vous confirmer que je considère
que ça fait partie de mes
responsabilités avec le directeur de
cabinet de regarder ces éléments et
d'intégrer évidemment tout
toutes les dimensions de 7,2 de cette
affaire qui serait susceptible
d'alimenter utilement une refonte de
notre de notre organisation
à cet égard je pense je saisis cette
occasion pour dire que il ya plusieurs
conséquences qu'il faudra tiens on a
d'ailleurs plusieurs enquêtes on a une
enquête justice judiciaire l' enquête
judiciaire permettra de conclure s'il ya
des sanctions individuelles à prendre en
particulier deuxièmement il ya des
enquêtes internes igpn
c'est une question qui relève du
gouvernement mais il me semblerait assez
logique que si j pn identifier les
dysfonctionnements il ne sera bon que le
gouvernement puisse y mettre fin
en particulier c'est le sens de
l'organisation de la préfecture de
police l'accueil d'observateurs gestion
de certains personnels enfin je pense
autant de questions qui mériteront
d'être regardé le moment venu et pour ce
qui me concerne pour ce qui concerne
l'organisation interne de la présidence
de la république
c'est évidemment des éléments c'est qui
qui devront être pris en compte dans la
définition de l'organisation future et
en particulier de l'organisation future
des des services qui concourent et qui
assure la sécurité le président a publié
comme la cabine est effectivement une
réflexion qui a été engagée sur ce point
parce qu'il ya deux services qui
assurent la protection et le secret le
président a un public de services
distincts
et ce qui est
n'apparaît pas nécessairement comme le
dispositif le plus efficace possible
c'est une question qu'on est en train de
regarder
regardez des enjeux de sécurité
je vous rassure tout de suite sur un
point native et des présents un public
demain comme aujourd'hui continuera
d'être assurée par des policiers et des
gendarmes et certainement pas par des
personnes du privé même s'ils peuvent
avoir une carrière d'autres expériences
et enfin je ne crois pas avoir identifié
à ce stade
d'autres manifestations que les trois
qui ont été mentionnés à savoir le
transfert des 2 2 d'antoine de simone
veil au panthéon le 14 juillet et mes
retours en tout cas en terme de
manifestations publiques mais je je je
je ferais regarder ce point de plus en
détail
je remercie monsieur buffet merci
monsieur le président monsieur morvan
hier également monsieur strzoda vous
même en début de cette réunion
vous nous avez indiqué ne pas savoir ne
pas avoir connaissance des relations
extrêmement tendues
je mesure mes mots entre monsieur
benalla et le j'espère la réponse est ce
matin dans ce grand journal du soir où
monsieur benalla déclare semble-t-il des
frictions oui mais sous forme de non
dits moi j'ai toujours fait les choses
n'ont pas pour ma personne mais dans
l'intérêt du président mais il ya des
gens qui sont formatés d'une autre façon
on fait le sale boulot et on s'expose
forcément
et quand on s'expose face à ce type de
personne ils vous disent oui avec un
sourire mais il ne l'oublient pas trois
points de suspension
je ne fais pas partie du club je le
ressens mais je dois en faire
abstraction car la seule chose qui
compte c'est que le président soit bien
ne pensez vous pas monsieur le
secrétaire général que cette déclaration
non seulement conforte les tensions
existantes mais de surcroît le rôle et
l'implication de monsieur benalla dans
la sécurité du président de la
république c'est le secrétaire général
je ne fais aucune conjectures sur une
déclaration que je n'ai pas lu et que je
découvre
non mais bien sûr je découvre en vous
écoutant je répèterai qu' aucun incident
ne met jamais remonté au camp je
répèterai que j'ai eu des retours très
positifs sur le travail qui nous menace
je n'ai aucun problème à dire je les
assume que c'est quelqu'un qui était
très engagé extrêmement dévoués
extrêmement disponibles comme je voulais
dire voilà je n'ai jamais travaillé
directement avait avec lui paraît que
ses deux collaborateurs directs dont il
ne faisait pas partie mais je n'ai eu
que des que des retours positifs sur son
engagement et son dévouement et je pense
et le président de la république s'est
exprimé sur ce sujet hier est
effectivement qui fait écho à un élément
que fait valoir alexandre benalla sur le
fait c'était quelqu'un qui avait un
profil différent et c'est tout à fait
vrai qu'elle est semblable à un profil
différent par rapport au type de profil
qu'on rencontre fréquemment dans les
couloirs de l'elysée je pense que c'est
aussi cet opposant à publica dit que
c'était quelque chose ne pouvait être
fier parce que c'est important aussi que
les services la présence d'un public
soit à l'image de notre pays et le fait
que mais qu' il est il et il est un
profil evian ce qui est ce qui est en
revanche important c'est que chacun
reste dans le cadre de ses
responsabilités et ça c'est ça la
question
c'est bien celle que de vous pose encore
le sénateur qui m'interroger sur une
question
exactement 2 mais c'était pas le cee
c'était précisément pas le sujet que de
la question et et de l'intervention de
l'interview plutôt d'alexandre benalla
que l'adhésion de ses fonctions mais
c'était la question du coup l'ambiance à
tort moi je vous réponds en tout cas sur
la dimension différence qu'effectivement
il ya une différence diversité je pense
que ce n'est pas forcément un problème
et quant au fait qu' il ait pu exister
des tensions dont je ne suis pas au
courant
ça me semblerait assez naturel je
connais peu d'organisation dans
lesquelles vous avez plusieurs dizaines
de personnes dans lequel vous n'avez
jamais attention enfin en tout cas
c'était c'était c'est assez rare et
d'autant qu effectivement du fait de et
tous ceux qui ont eu à connaître du
fonctionnement de l'ue chefferie de
cabinet savent que l'équipe de la
chefferie de cabinet sont toujours des
gens qui sont assez jalouser parce que
ils ont cette dimension de proximité
avec l'autorité qui suscite toujours une
certaine une certaine envie et donc vous
constaterez toujours que dans un cabinet
ministériel présidentielle prix
ministériel le chef de cabinet au son
équipe rapprochée qui ont un accès
direct à la personnalité sont toujours
des gens qu'on con con envira alors mes
chers collègues je m'y attendais c'est
une audition importante dépassant le
temps nécessaire c'est normal vous
faites les uns et les autres des efforts
de concision dans vos questions je vous
en remercie il était important que cette
audition ait lieu
j'ai encore plusieurs demandes de
questions je vais vous proposer de les
grouper comme nous l'avons fait hier
pour le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république
de sorte que nous puissions amener cette
audition à conclusions dans une dizaine
de minutes compte tenu du débordement je
crois utile que nous avons déjà
enregistré dans le temps dévolu à nos
travaux
monsieur buffet vous vouliez juste
ajouter un point ou faire vous vous
posez votre question mais très
rapidement
ce serait je m'abstiens de toute
intervention nouvelle je vous remercie
alors je donne la parole à monsieur le
comte qu'il a demandé aussi et donc tout
en permettant de regretter cette
accélération alors que nous avons déjà
une certaine expérience depuis deux
jours ça ne raccourcit pas vos questions
chères mais je préfère le dire si vous
voulez mais si vous voulez monsieur le
président j'ai trois cours de
précédentes auditions à l'isi j'ai trois
questions la première les banques les
bandes de vidéosurveillance qui ont été
obtenues de manière irrégulière ont
elles été exploité par la présidence de
la république
la deuxième question au regard du statut
du président de la république comment
faut-il comprendre la phrase qu'il
vienne me chercher par rapport aux
initiatives de l'autorité judiciaire ou
du pouvoir législatif
suite aux révélations du monde du 18
juillet enfin on constate troisième
question que l'un des principaux
problèmes de cette affaire c'est la
prééminence sur l'ensemble de nos
institutions de la présidence de la
république
on constate que vous avez pris
d'initiative enfin le président de
république de partager des conseillers
entre le président la république et le
gouvernement
on constate une faiblesse importante des
effectifs des cabinets ministériels qui
ont du mal à fonctionner seul tout cela
concourt au renforcement du de la
présidence de la république par rapport
au gouvernement
est-ce que compte tenu de ce que nous
observons actuellement vous en tirer des
conclusions sur le fonctionnement de
l'état et les corrections à apporter lui
merci de cette question est en plein
dans le sujet effectivement de ce que
nous croyons être des dysfonctionnements
et des risques de confusion des pouvoirs
et incidemment la question vous avez
posé de la souligner sur le fait qu'il
existe aujourd'hui des conseillers qui
soit à la fois conseiller du président
de la république et conseiller du
premier ministre n'est t'elle pas source
de confusion dans la séparation des
pouvoirs constitutionnels entre le
président de la république et le premier
ministre alors nous continuons avec
madame arriver merci monsieur président
la question est simple en cours à la
modification des missions de monsieur
benalla après la mise à pied caractérise
la rétrogration après avoir appris qu'il
n'y avait pas eu de suspension de
salaire 1 pour l'instant et que pour des
raisons de logistique et de nombre
d'agents il avait été convié un certain
nombre de manifestations auxquelles ils
n'auraient pas dû participer et sa
enclenche une deuxième question comment
expliquer le silence entre le 2 mai et
le 18 juillet est la réponse que fait
monsieur benalla je n'ai pas commis un
délit mais une faute politique
merci madame marie b monsieur bonhomme
ainsi monsieur le président monsieur
secteur général je vois une point de
précisions par rapport aux la question
de mes collègues tout à l'heure
concernant les obligations déclaratives
auprès de la haute autorité
vous avez dit sur un autre point la loi
a été respectée
vous avez ajouté je ne m'occupe pas de
d'autres détails plus accessoire comme
ça mes obligations déclaratives je
n'aurai pas le cam qui n'avait 2 donc
déclaration d'intérêt déclaration de
situation patrimoniale qui auraient pu
s'ils les avaient été respectées vous
éclairer sur la nature et 21 des liens
qui pouvaient exister entre monsieur
benalla est par exemple des sociétés
privées de sécurité
elle aurait pu au demeurant conformément
à l'esprit de la loi sur la transparence
dans les publics
développez votre culture déontologiques
et prévenir tout conflit d'intérêts donc
ces mouvements sont non seulement sont
constitutifs d'un délit et relève comme
ça a été dit d'une saisine de la haute
autorité et du parquet moi je vois
savoir aujourd'hui est ce que vous savez
qu'on forme confirmé vous donc que la
loi n'a pas été respectée
de votre point de vue aujourd'hui parce
que vous avez indiqué que vous aviez
interrogé au service pour connaître la
pratique hors la loi dans son article 2
1 son article 11 2013 extrêmement clair
ça d'ailleurs été tranchée lors du débat
parlementaire l'époque ici même
les collaborateurs du président y
compris ceux qui ne figurent pas sur la
liste relève de ses obligations
déclaratives
donc je ne comprends pas pourquoi vous
avez cette interprétation vous avez même
interrogé au service sur pour
interpréter un élément qui était tout à
fait clair dès le début
merci c'est une question qui est à
d'ailleurs été déjà abordé tout à leur
chère collègue monsieur alain marc
merci président monsieur le secrétaire
des syndicats de policiers ici l'autre
jour nous ont affirmé que monsieur
benalla avait recruté des vigiles ont
recruté des villes par l'intermédiaire
d'une société de sécurité
est ce que vous avez eu connaissance de
cela vous nous avez dit que à votre
connaissance hier
ne pensez pas que cela pouvait exister
si cela était le cas cela sous la double
lauréat l'elysée et pour loin si ce
n'était pas le cas s'il se met enfin si
c'était le cas ici se mêler aux services
de la gendarmerie et de la police vous
comprenez le problème que nous aurions
dans la sécurité organisée et surtout
est-ce que vous pouvez nous affirmer
donc que cela d'où cela ne double n'est
pas à l'elysée ou à tout le moins que
cela brouillonnet et peut-être et enfin
monsieur henri leroy
le 2 mai vous apprenez que un des
collaborateurs du cabinet a commis des
infractions usurpation de qualité le
port illégal d'un signe de la police et
puis ensuite vous apprenez aussi peu
importe le cheminement puisque je dois
être très très bref vous apprenez que il
s'est fait porter les les
les cds de vidéos pour visionner
effectivement la manifestation tout ça
effectivement ils susceptibles de
constituer un délit
or vous estimez que ce n'est pas le cas
c'est à dire où vous êtes substituer ou
encore de la république puisque
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénal
dit que toute autorité constituée doit
apporter à sa connaissance des faits
susceptibles de constituer un crime ou
un délit
donc c'est à lui d'apprécier et non pas
une quelconque autorité du moment
qu'elle a connaissance de ces faits or
vous les avez et vous n'avez pas rempli
l'obligation de l'article 40
voilà ma question pourquoi et quand
pensez-vous après surtout
rétrospectivement de toutes les fautes
qu'a commis cet individu monsieur le
secrétaire général vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup alors prendre les
questions telles qu'elles ont été posées
dans dans l'ordre le sénateur le qu'on
devait interroger sur
la bande de vidéosurveillance sur cette
question dès lors qu'il a été
kylie a eu un doute sur l'origine de
cette
vidéo à l'occasion de la fois par an à
travers une alerte qui nous est venue de
la préfecture de police est ensuite à
l'occasion d'une réunion que j'ai que
j'ai tenu le jour même nous avons décidé
de
posséder un signalement au titre de
précisément l'article 40 de restituer ou
d'adressé e
les éléments dont nous disposions pas de
vidéo aux procureurs et d'engager compte
tenu de ces éléments d'engager le
licenciement d'alexandre benalla
précisément sur cette base donc et
vraiment je dirais dans les moins de 24
heures md que dès que nous avons eu le
moindre doute
interrogé cette déclaration du président
de la république et sur lequel je crois
que sa volonté était simplement de il
l'exprimé du reste lui même hier en
marge de son de son déplacement fait
qu'il refusait une république des
fusibles dans laquelle on chercherait
des des boucs émissaires et pour
indépendamment de des fautes qui
auraient été commises alors qu'eux ils
estiment de manière ultime être
responsable et responsable devant les
français est exclusivement devant les
français comme vous le savez est tel que
le dit notre constitution il y a des
conseillers communs attendez qu'il
vienne me chercher à votre selon votre
interprétation i ls qu'il sait qui mais
je pense que il s'adresse à tous ceux
qui dénoncent eux son action qui
saisissent cette affaire pour en faire
une
un procès de nature politique il ne
s'agit en rien d'esquiver de quelconque
responsabilité de nature judiciaire
il est des poursuites en cours de nature
administrative
il ya une expression interne en cours de
manière disciplinée
une édition qui ont été prises qui ont
connu une sanction ou pire un
licenciement
il y aura des conséquences à en tirer
est que ce soit sur l'organisation des
d'éventuelles sanctions mais si c'est
précisément la question je vous me
demandez d'interpréter la déclaration du
président de la république le dit qu'il
répond à ceux qui dénoncent le fait
qu'il aurait une forme de 2,2 des skiffs
de responsabilité ce que ça n'est pas
mais pardon son statut je vous confirme
que le présent la public par la
constitution est effectivement été
responsable il est responsable devant
les français il l'a réaffirmé je reviens
sur votre question sur les conseillers
comme a effectivement je vous confirme
qu'il doit y avoir une croix une
douzaine de conseillers communs entre le
cabinet pro mini c'est le cabinet
président de la république dans une
chaîne domaines très variés et ce qui a
été examiné par construction par les
services compétents il serait d'agir du
gouvernement et qui ne voit pas en quoi
posent difficulté
du point de vue de séparation des
pouvoirs
y compris au sein du pouvoir exécutif
arrivez vous n'avez interrogé sur la
question de la rétrogradation et sur les
modalités
en tout cas je crois pouvoir vous dire
je ne sais pas ce que monsieur bédard a
dit dans son interview mais que en tout
cas la modification du périmètre de ses
responsabilités a très clairement été
perçue vécu et compris par l'intéressé
comme étant une rétrogradation voir une
forme de d'humiliation en tout cas
vis-à-vis de 2,2
de ses collègues et cette sanction
n'ayant pas du tout été je ne fais que
vous dire comment elle a été perçu par
l'intéressé dans le monde s'il vous
plaît
interrompu dès lors qu'il n'ya jamais eu
la moindre dissimulation de cette
sanction je puis vous dire que la
sanction était très largement connues de
ces de ses collègues et je comprends que
c'est pu contribuer à accentuer son
ressenti c'est le sénateur john holmes
vous n'avez interrogé sur la saisine de
la haute autorité
je crois avoir déjà répondu à cette
question suite au aux débats qui ont eu
lieu ici même hier j'ai procédé aux
diligences nécessaires j'ai interrogé le
secrétaire général du gouvernement qui
m'a indiqué que selon lui il était
préférable de solliciter les intéressés
afin qu'ils se manifestent auprès de la
haute autorité
pour ce qui est des circonstances de
l'époque je vous confirme que nous
n'avons fait que suivre peut-être à tort
la neige et rennais que nous le dira la
pratique qui avait prévalu à la
présidence de la république sur cette
question au cours de la mandature
précédente
monsieur le sénateur mark ouvert
interrogé sur le recrutement de vigiles
mais je pense pas avoir déjà répondu en
tout état de cause je ne pourrais pas
vous dire qu' aucun des membres du
j'espère n'ont pas eu dans leur vie un
moment donné ou un autre une activité de
sécurité puis jeunes pour tout vous dire
je ne je ne le sais pas mais en tout
état de cause il n'y a pas d'autres
membres que les membres du j'espère de
commandement militaire qui assure la
sécurité du président de la république
et certainement pas des vigiles privés
des derniers points interrogé sur
l'article 40 mais sur le fait que
substituer à pouvoir d'appréciation du
procureur au cas d'espèce comme je l'aï
dit tout à l'heure je ne disposais pas à
l'époque d' élément me permettant de
penser qu'une infraction pénale de
nature délictuelle été commise je crois
que c'est une question qui aujourd'hui
sera tranché elle sera tranchée par par
la justice je vous remercie
merci monsieur le secrétaire général un
aspect important des questions qui ont
été posées
c'est la question de monsieur le comte
sur l'existence tout à fait officielle
de proches conseillers du président de
la république qui sont également des
proches conseillers du premier ministre
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de nos institutions que ce choix a été
fait vous nous dites que vous ne voyez
pas ce qui pourrait y avoir de contraire
à la séparation des pouvoirs
par cette forme d'organisation
je vous précise que c'est pour nous un
questionnement important car les titres
de la constitution qui traitent des
responsabilités du gouvernement et bien
sûr distincte du titre de la
constitution qui traitent des
responsabilités du président de la
république elles ne sont pas de même
nature
le gouvernement dispose de
l'administration et de la force armée
lui seul exerce à travers les ministres
une autorité sur les directeurs
d'administration centrale et le premier
ministre à travers son cabinet prend des
décisions ces décisions figure dans les
relevés de conclusions des réunions
interministérielles qu'on appelle
communément les bleus et si un
conseiller du président de la république
est également content
ayez du premier ministre on est en droit
de se demander si la décision du
gouvernement est une décision du
président de la république ou une
décision du gouvernement or le président
de la république
de par son statut constitutionnel n'est
pas responsable devant le parlement ni
sur le plan pénal
pendant la durée de ses fonctions et
pour les décisions qu'il prend en
application de ses compétences
constitutionnelles tandis que le
gouvernement est responsable devant le
parlement
si bien que quand un conseiller du
premier ministre prend une décision qui
a été validée sous forme de bleu de
matignon pour utiliser le langage commun
cette décision engage la responsabilité
du gouvernement devant le parlement et
peut faire l'objet d'un contrôle du
parlement au titre de sa mission de
contrôle du gouvernement mais si cette
décision peut apparaître comme une
décision d'un collaborateur du président
de la république
la situation est tout autre si bien que
je crois que il ya là une véritable
question sur la séparation dans un
régime de dualité de l'exécutif entre
présidence de la république et
gouvernement qui méritent d'être
traitées et il me semble que la question
de monsieur le cours de ce point de vue
là était tout à fait léviter mais
puisque ce qui fait l'objet de notre
commission denquête c'est justement
l'interférence d'un conseiller du
président de la république avec le
fonctionnement normal d'une
administration au cours d'une opération
de maintien de l'ordre
je suis obligé de vous dire de même que
vous avez faits examinés à la suite de
notre
auditions d'hier du directeur de cabinet
la question des déclarations d'intérêt
de patrimoine des collaborateurs du
président de la république auprès de la
haute autorité qui alla de mon point de
vue une sorte de désordre institutionnel
et de confusion à laquelle je crois
qu'il serait bon de remédier je voulais
vous le dire j'ai bien entendu la
réponse que vous nous avez fait tout à
l'heure je crois que avec beaucoup de
spontanéité
vous avez considéré qu'il n'y avait pas
de problème que personne ne vous l'avez
signalé
et bien je vous le signale parce que ça
n'est pas une question simple ce n'est
pas une question banale
c'est la fusion du gouvernement et de la
présidence de la république et cette
fusion n'est pas prévu par la
constitution
monsieur le secrétaire général vous
voulez peut-être réellement ainsi
monsieur le président je réagirais très
très très rapidement il simplement pour
vous dire que bon c'est une question qui
relève de l'organisation du pouvoir
exécutif donc dû par exécutif avec avec
lui-même je pense pas que ce soit une
question qui touche à la séparation des
pouvoirs
et pour ce qui est de l'organisation des
au sein de l'exécutif et du rôle des
cabinets vous avez occupé le poste que
j'ai l'honneur d'occuper aujourd'hui
vous savez bien que tu es la préhistoire
et l'ancien monde je veux bien
reconnaître qu'une référence
je pense que ce sens est sur le point
que je vais soulever
je crois pouvoir vous dire par
anticipation que rien n'a changé
les conseillers des cabinets
ministériels ne sont pas des autorités
politiques n'ont pas vocation à se
substituer à elle et que quels que
soient le fait que les conseillers
soient communs ou pas à la fin et je
pense qu'il est bon qu'il en soit ainsi
et qu'il le reste
longtemps c'est bien l'autorité
politique de prendre des décisions
ce ne sont pas les conseillers
techniques
les conseillers qui prennent les
décisions ce ne sont pas eux qui signent
décret ce ne sont pas eux qui signent
des acteurs de nature réglementaire et
il serait pour le coup
mauvais pour l'occasion de notre pays
qu'il en soit ainsi et pour cette raison
ne serait ce que pour cette raison je
pense que la difficulté ou que vous
voulez voir ne me ment semble pas être
une session était peut-être enfin je
suis désolé de conclure sur ce sur ce
désaccord en fait c'est votre
appréciation de monsieur le secrétaire
général madame jourdain me demander la
parole je la lui donne pour une team
question
merci monsieur le président alors je ne
sais pas si nous allons rester sur un
désaccord secrétaire général mais il y
en a en tout cas entre les déclarations
qui nous ont été faites de monsieur le
directeur de cabinet qui parlant de la
sanction infligée
monsieur b d'allah nous a confirmé hier
avoir pris seul cette décision tandis
que publiquement monsieur le président
de la république a déclaré mardi que
c'était lui qui avait confirmé la
sanction
pouvez vous nous éclairer sur cette
contradiction s'il vous plaît j'ai
répondu incidemment à 7 à cette question
en indiquant qu' il n'y a pas eu de
débat entre nous parce que le principe
de la sanction
la décision de la sanction était de
l'ordre de l'évidence
taylor de l'évidence qu'elle intervienne
rapidement et qu'elles soient notifiées
rapidement donc le directeur de cabinet
m'a informé m'a rendu compte de dès le
premier jour de son souhait de le
principe de prendre une sanction et
julie lui ai donné mon plein accord
ça me semblait de l'ordre de l'univers
j'en ai rendu compte au président de la
république et le lendemain l'informer de
la décision qui allait être notifiée à
monsieur b nana et je lui ai confirmé
mon plein accord avec cette décision et
j'en ai rendu compte au prix d'un mac
merci monsieur
le secrétaire général ce sera le mot de
la fin monsieur le secrétaire général je
vais vous remettre la lettre que les
rapporteurs et moi-même venons de signer
pour vous demander quelques compléments
d'informations qui sont apparus
nécessaire au fil des questions qui ont
été posées et des réponses que vous avez
apporté je suspends la séance je demande
aux membres de la commission des lois de
rester nous auditionnons une
personnalité en vue d'une nomination
pour la fonction de médiateur du crédit
je vous remercie et voilà pour cette
longue audition d'alexis colère le
secrétaire général de l'elysée est
questionné dans le calme par la
commission d' enquête sénatoriale qui
lui a posé de très nombreuses questions
relatives aux dysfonctionnements de
l'elysée d'ailleurs certains ont déjà
été admis par emmanuel macron sur
l'organisation de la sécurité
présidentielle
la proportion est la réalité de la
sanction ou encore le permis de port
d'armé et les pratiques de l'elysée en
matière de transparence
tout cela en plus été percuté par le
grand entretien qui a été donné par
alexandre benalla dans le monde qui
vient d'être dévoilée par le quotidien
mais tout d'abord et bien le secrétaire
général de l'elysée a tenu à rappeler
dans son propos liminaire qu'il n'y a
pas de police parallèle
à l'elysée on écoute et on en parle ça
près compte tenu de l'audition du
directeur de cabinet patrick strzoda
hier devant vous et devant les députés
de celle du commandant militaire du
palais de l'elysée le général bio farina
et du chef du j espère le colonel
lavergne
je pense j'espère que vous avez été
rassuré sur le fait qu'il n'existe pas à
l'elysée de police parallèle que nous
n'employons pas de vigiles privés pour
protéger le chef de l'état et que
monsieur benalla n'a jamais été en
charge de la protection du président de
la république
voilà pour cet extrait ce temps fort de
l'audition que l'on a pu entendre tout à
l'heure celle d'alexis colère le
secrétaire général de l'elysée qui vient
de sortir de la salle clémenceau et on
entend tout de suite et bien le
rapporteur socialiste de la commission
denquête jean pierre sueur en
particulier il nous a beaucoup été dit
comme monsieur ben alla n'avait aucune
fonction de police
or le port d'armes lui a été attribué à
la demande de l'elysée avec un arrêté
dont nous avons donné lecture qui écrit
considérant que monsieur benalla
exercent des fonctions de police donc il
ya une contradiction
deuxièmement après les 15 jours de mise
à pied de monsieur ben alla il a
continué à exercer des fonctions il a
été présent pour le 14 juillet dans la
tribune officielle
il a été présent pour accueillir les
bleus en particulier à roissy le
quelques discussions avec la gendarmerie
il a été peu présent au panthéon
lors de l'arrivée des cendres de simone
veil et antoine vélomoteurs et on ne
peut pas dire que c'était des fonctions
qui étaient devenus administrative d'une
autre nature et nous avons eu
véritablement et nous avons toujours le
sentiment d'une confusion des rôles est
d'ailleurs le porte parole de l'elysée a
dit qu'après sa mise à pied il
n'exerçait plus de fonctions de
protection de sécurité
or on a vraiment le sentiment qu'il a
continué après comme avant la réalité
c'est qu'une sanction a été prise après
le 2 mai mais le 2 mai il était
impossible d'ignorer premièrement qu'il
avait usurpé des signes distinctifs de
la police nationale
ce qui est un délit et qu'il avait fait
usage de la force à l'égard de citoyens
de ce pays donc il aurait été légitime
de que la justice fut saisie en vertu de
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénale
que vous connaissez bien maintenant or
il est apparu puisque nous avons
interrogé tout le monde il est apparu
que le nil préfet de police ni le
ministre de l'intérieur ne l'avait fait
considérable a relevé de l'elysée et que
personne à l'elysée ne l'a fait à ce
moment là alors il est certain que la
police que la justice excusez-moi a été
saisie mais à la fin du mois de juillet
quand il a paris il est apparu une autre
faute de monsieur benalla puisqu'il a
demandé à trois fonctionnaires dieu la
préfecture de police de disposer des
vidéos donnent à ce moment là il ya une
sanction mais très franchement on ne
comprend pas pourquoi la saisine de la
justice n'est pas intervenu dès le 2 mai
dont il y a beaucoup de précision qui
ont été apportées c'est vrai voilà pour
cette intervention devant les
journalistes du co rapporteur socialiste
jean pierre sueur donc interrogé juste
devant la salle où s'est déroulée
l'audition et j'accueille sur ce plateau
le président du groupe socialiste au
sénat patrick kanner bonjour bonjour
merci d'être avec moi pour revenir sur
cette audition que vous avez suivi un
comme de nombreux autres depuis quelques
jours tout d'abord pour revenir sur ce
que disait jean pierre sueur y at il eu
un flou au niveau de la fonction
d'alexandre benalla un flou qui a été
pointée du doigt et qui demeure malgré
et bien ces auditions on a du mal à
avoir des éclaircissements
je suis naturellement vous répondre mais
permettez-moi d'abord de féliciter que
au sénat monsieur koller a été invité
qu'il a pu s'exprimer manière
républicaine c'est important oui il ya
eu il ya un flou il ya un flou permettez
moi de vous plaît patrick est la
priorité
odiah carrosserie l'iba le rapporteur de
la commission rappelé le président de la
commission des lois sénateurs les
républicains est au micro de jérôme
rabier juste devant la salle clémenceau
où s'est déroulée tout à l'heure
l'audition on vous écoute jérôme c'est à
vous exactement à être philippe bas
alors philippe bas vous sortez tout
juste de cette audition d'alexis kohler
secrétaire général de l'elysée est ce
que vous avez eu des réponses
satisfaisantes à vos questions c'est une
audition ce n'est pas une comparution la
commission denquête n'est pas un
tribunal elle ne prendra pas de sanction
elle ne procède pas par condamnation
mais elle veut savoir la vérité
elle veut résoudre un certain nombre de
contradictions sur de nombreux points la
situation aujourd'hui est encore celle
d'un grand flou il y à des
contradictions entre ce que nous disent
les autorités de la présidence de la
république sur les fonctions de monsieur
benalla est ce que la préfecture de
police elle même aperçu de ses fonctions
quand elle a attribué son port d'armes
il y a dans le statut de monsieur pénale
à un cumul de moyens d'action le
logement la voiture de police la carte
d'accès à l'elysée le port d'armes qui
jette le trouble sur la réalité de sa
fonction était il un garde du corps
était-il dans une fonction
administrative d'organisation de
déplacement toutes ces question méritait
d'être posée et je dois dire que
à l'issue de ces premières auditions ne
se dégage pas l'impression d'une grande
clarté
justement est ce que la question des
deux les réponses d'alexis kohler vous
satisfait dans cette quête de la vérité
qui est la vôtre
la secrétaire général de la présidence
de la république sur plusieurs points
n'a fait que réitérer les propos du
directeur du cabinet que nous avions
entendu hier et n'a pas levé toutes les
autres dont beaucoup font est important
pour nous maintenant c'est d'arriver à
dégager des propositions de sorte que hu
n'est pas de confusion des pouvoirs que
les collaborateurs du président de la
république ne puisse pas interférer avec
le fonctionnement des administrations et
notamment ici de la police chacun son
rôle le président a un rôle
constitutionnel
il est élu par les français il donne
l'impulsion à l'action mais il n'est pas
participants à l'exécution est par
ailleurs il n'est pas responsable devant
le parlement le premier ministre
l'est par conséquent s'il interfère avec
l'action gouvernementale cela crée de la
confusion sommes dans un système où il y
à une prééminence présidentielle et
c'est heureux pour notre pays et cette
prééminence ça n'est pas absorber tous
les pouvoirs il y à la séparation entre
le parlement et entre la présidence de
la république il ya la séparation avec
la justice bien sûr mais il ya aussi une
autre séparation qu'on a perdus de vue
c'est la séparation entre le président
de la république qui est au sommet et le
gouvernement qui la constitution le dit
dispose de l'administration lorsqu'il
met en oeuvre
la politique de la nation et c'est le
gouvernement et lui seul qui est présent
au parlement pour faire aboutir les
réformes et faire adopter la loi et donc
je crois qu'il est grand temps de
remettre un petit peu d'ordre qu'il n'y
ait pas un pouvoir qui absorbe tous les
autres de respecter les contre-pouvoirs
mais de respecter aussi les pouvoirs qui
au sein de l'exécutif sont bien sûr
inégaux rapport au président de la
république mais sont distinctes
c'est quelque chose qui peut paraître
subtil mais qui est très important dans
l'état de droit dans la république que
nos institutions fonctionnent dans
l'ordre car ce que révèle cette affaire
banale à ces de la confusion dans le
fonctionnement de l'état de droit et
dans le fonctionnement de notre
république
une dernière question sur la convocation
monsieur alexis kohler la commission
denquête à l'assemblée n'a pas souhaité
faire ce choix la majorité la république
en marche n'a pas souhaité l'audition
d'haïti kohler c'était nécessaire pour
vous et bénéfique qu'il vienne
s'expliquer ici devant le sénat c'est le
numéro un de l'équipe du président il
voit le président tous les jours ce
qu'il nous dit ça n'est pas tout à fait
la parole du président mais presque et
donc nous avions effectivement besoin
d'aller jusque là dans nos
investigations nous respectons la
présidence de la république la
présidence de la république à manifester
son respect pour le travail du sénat en
permettant cette audition de monsieur
colère qui est prévu par les textes sur
les commissions d'enquêté
nous avons la possibilité de convoquer
qui nous voulons entendre mais vous
voyez qu'il ya chez nous le souci non
pas de chercher à trouver des coupables
mais le souci de comprendre ce qui s'est
passé et le souci de faire des
préconisations qui amélioreront le
fonctionnement de l'état et le respect
du rôle de chaque institution
merci beaucoup philippe bas pour cette
première réaction à la sortie de la
commission enquête qui a donc auditionné
alexis kohler
merci beaucoup jérôme pour cette
réaction on vous retrouve de que vous
avez d'une nouvelle personnalité à votre
micro
patrick kanner je reprends sur la
question que je vous pose est à savoir
est ce que il ya une confusion au niveau
d'alexandre benalla du flou et
d'ailleurs et bien on entendait philippe
bas le dire ça reflète une confusion des
genres une confusion des pouvoirs le
mode aux confusions et et forme il est
juste et le président bah raison de
l'utiliser il ya des dysfonctionnements
majeurs
finalement le travail de la presse a été
utile et cela a permis de souligner ces
dysfonctionnements parce que monsieur
benalla serait encore en responsabilité
importante à l'elysée avec tous les
avantages évoqué qui sont maintenant
cibler d'ailleurs sûrement certains
indues comme ce port d'armes de dents
touche tous demandent à quoi il a
vraiment servi
donc nous mettons les choses sur la
place publique
non pas pour jeter l'opprobre sur qui
que ce soit non pas pour mettre en
difficulté le temps de la république
mais pour dire mais il y à un
dysfonctionnement plus haut sommet de
l'état et le travail du sénat permet de
le mettre en exergue et jacques
actuellement sur ce plateau muriel
jourda bonjour vous êtes sénatrice les
républicains rapporteur de cette
commission denquête que pensez-vous
effectivement de ce flou de cette
gravité peut-être qu'il peut y avoir
dans ce flou je vous fait également
réagir à ce que vient de dire emmanuel
macron vient de déclarer que cette
affaire benalla c'est une tempête dans
un verre d'eau
alors nous allons voir pour la tempête
dans un verre d'eau je pense que nous
serons à la fin de nos auditions et
lorsque nous arriverons à nos
conclusions
et tout cela n'est pas encore terminée
pour le reste c'est à dire pour la
confusion qui existe effectivement ça
encore une fois arrivés à des
conclusions avant la fin de cette
enquête
il y a des éléments qui reste douteux
dans l'esprit de tout le monde depuis
hier et ce matin je pense que mon
collègue le président kader sera
d'accord avec moi rien n'a été éclairés
de ce point de vue là il y a deux choses
jusqu'à ce que bis repetita par rapport
à ce qu'a pu dire hier monsieur patrick
strzoda beaucoup de confusion on va dire
que également le langage sont les mêmes
les éléments de langage sont les mêmes
il ya deux points qui restent en
discussion assez sérieux
il nous est indiqué que monsieur
médaille a été rétrogradé avec des
missions inférieure à celle qu'il avait
avant on a le sentiment qu'il exerce
toujours les mêmes et il est assez
difficile de caractériser la différence
le deuxième point c'est effectivement
son rôle auprès du président de la
république dans le cadre la sécurité
rapprochée président la république qui
est sur ce point tout le monde est
d'accord ne peut être assurée que par
des professionnels fonctionnaires civils
ou militaires
disons que la réalité contredit les
éléments de langage qui nous sont
données lui qui effectivement être
chargée de la protection des manuels
macron pendant la campagne on nous dit
ensuite qu'il était en charge de
l'organisation et d'ailleurs tout cela
est reflétée par et bien toutes les
discussions qu'il ya peu avoir sur la
question du port d'armes vous propose de
revenir à ce passage important lors de
l'audition la question du port d'armes
on va voir si vous avez été satisfait ou
non par la réponse qui a été porté par
alexis kohler le secrétaire général de
l'elysée on écoute et on commence juste
après et qu'est ce qui dans sa fonction
grande est utile pour la présidence de
la république que monsieur bénard est un
permis de port d'armes
franchement je suppose tout simplement
que comme vous l'avait indiqué le
dispositif de sécurité est adapté à
l'intensité de la de la menace et au
contexte dans lequel se situe le
président de la république il est
toujours j'insiste il est tout oui tout
à fait il y à des services et ce sont
toujours ces services qui sont en charge
c'est toujours le gspr qui est en charge
lorsque le présent d'un public est en
déplacement
je pense simplement je suppose que dans
certaines circonstances il a été jugé
qu' il pouvait être utile que d'autres
puissent apporter leur concours
mais vous les interrogez il n'en reste
pas moins j insiste sur ce point
monsieur le sénateur parce que vous vous
avez l'air de trouver ça curieux mais
c'est ainsi c'est toujours le j'espère
qu'ils aient sur la protection président
la république le chef du j'espère l'a
dit alors est-ce que la réponse alexis
kohler sur ce point a été satisfaisante
patrick kanner avec les morts absolument
pas un port d'armes
encore une fois à quoi il sert
lieutenant-colonel de réserve à 26 ans
une voiture et qui met police non ça ne
ne marche pas c'est un système de
privilèges
voilà peut-être la proximité historique
de monsieur benalla avec monsieur
maquereau a pu aboutir à cela je bien
senti dans les réactions de monsieur
macron que voilà il savait était trop
loin
manifestement mais c'est grave parce que
c'était un proche un très proche et même
s'ils n'étaient pas dans la garde
rapprochée de la sécurité nous dit on
manifestement toutes les images montrent
qu'ils étaient là en protection du
président républicain fenêtre pas
d'accord avec ce qu'a pu dire emmanuel
macron quand il parle de tempête dans un
verre d'eau
tempête dans un verre d'eau le vern le
verre d'eau est grand et puis c'est
assez choquant je trouve
parce que le ver dos et qui sait le
parlement cc commission denquête à force
d'affaiblir le parlement
les corps intermédiaires la presse les
collectivités territoriales on
s'aperçoit finalement une forme
d'hypertrophie du pouvoir exécutif qui à
mon avis n'est pas dans l'esprit de la
vème république ne rien jourda vous en
parliez également tout à l'heure la
question de la sanction la sanction elle
n'a pas été clair on a lu hier bien ces
révélations de patrick strzoda qui a
bien indiqué
que il avait reçu son salaire complet au
mois de mai contrairement à ce qu'on
avait pu penser avec les propos du
porte-parole bruno roger petit et puis
là il ya eu cette expression qu'avait
philippe à une sanction très rapide mais
finalement une exécution très longtemps
tout à fait c'était c'est aussi à une
des questions qui s'est posé sur la
réalité de cette sanction qui laisse
encore une fois planer une certaine
confusion sur le statut de monsieur b
dallas puisque ce retrait de
rémunération n'a pas été effectif il ne
l'est peut-être pas encore nous le
serons puisque nous avons demandé ces
fiches de paye à la présidence de la
république
et puis encore une fois la
rétrogradation ne relève pas de
l'évidence
dans la réalité des faits le souci c'est
que nous avons des faits qui sont sur
cette matière contredit par ce que nous
indique la présidence de la république
par l'intermédiaire de son directeur de
cabinet comme de son secrétaire général
qu'il faut éclaircir cela car on touche
effectivement aux institutions et puis à
la protection du président de la
république et nous avons vu dans le
journal le monde et que monsieur b
dallas a donné une interview en disant
lui-même qu'il y avait des frictions ce
qui nous est totalement démentie en tout
cas on nous dit on n'a aucun retour
ça aussi c'est peut-être un problème de
fonctionnement s'il ya des frictions et
qu'on n'arrive pas le savoir dans un
service aussi important que celui de la
sécurité rapprochée oui ça y est la
brique châtaigniers à plusieurs reprises
ses collections par les différents
responsables que l'on a pu entendre
qu'ils ont tous dit on nous n'avons que
des retours très positifs sur monsieur
ben ali et voilà que des trente ans dans
cet entretien au monde alexandre bédat
l'a dit lui même qu'il y avait des
inimitiés qui d'ailleurs nous nous amène
tout cas pour le groupe socialiste a
demandé son audition devant la
commission denquête naturellement en
séparant la partie judiciaire de la
partie administrative qui nous intéresse
en tant que tel puisque monsieur mais
dallas s'exprime qui vient aussi
s'exprimer devant les parlementaires
à partir de là cela conforte finalement
les propos du début des auditions avec
les syndicats de police 110 ans mais
monsieur benalla outre passe est
manifestement ses fonctions avec une
forme d'autoritarisme sur les policiers
cela confirme finalement des débordement
d'émotions
il faisait notamment monsieur benalla
encore un dysfonctionnement et pourquoi
est il pas été protégé comme cela
comment at il été protégé c'est la
question qui tue
aujourd'hui muriel jourda oui on non on
s'interroge effectivement sur
l'adéquation de la réaction ce qui s'est
passé sur un sujet encore une fois
extrêmement sensible oui d'ailleurs pas
remis et bien les interrogations et
l'adéquation de la réaction et à la
question de l'article 40
le fait d'aller saisir ou pas la justice
il en a été question tout à l'heure et
d'ailleurs vous allez le voir alexis
kohler assume de n'avoir pas eu recours
à l'article 40 le 2 mai pour lui cela ne
justifiait pas à cette époque
en l'écoutant et ce qui aurait porté
atteinte la présence de la public de
façon particulièrement aiguës graves
soit et qu'il n'y aurait pas eu de
réaction n'est pas eu de sanctions et
c'est pour ça qu on a encore une fois
insisté pour qu'ils aient une sanction
qu'il soit rapide et pour ce qui est de
l'article 40
compte tenu des éléments dont je dispose
et je n'avais pas d'un élément me
permettant de penser qu'une saisine au
titre de l'article 40 serait justifié
j'ajoute pour être plus explicite
vous avez cité un nombre d'autorités qui
ont été informés
au niveau du gouvernement ou ailleurs et
qu'aucune autorité qui a eu à connaître
de ces faits n'a à ma connaissance a
même suggéré l'opportunité d'un article
muriel jourda vous n'avez pas l'air du
tout satisfaite 1 par cette réponse
d'alexis non colère ça reste à démontrer
qu'il ne fallait pas saisir l'article 40
disons que la réponse est plus délicate
que celle qui était faite puisque
monsieur colère s'abrite derrière la
décision plutôt la non décision de ceux
qui ont vu la vidéo également
il faut savoir que lorsque l'igpn a vu
cette vidéo et police
exactement la police des polices elle
n'était pas au courant les personnes qui
l'ont visionné des passes au courant de
ce qu'ils ne s'agissait pas d'un
policier mais d'un observateur et
lorsque la question a été posée en
audition à madame la directrice de
l'igpn de savoir ce qu'elle aurait fait
qu était la marche à suivre si elle
avait connu la qualité d'observateur de
la personne qu'ils commettaient des
violences elle a été sans ambiguïté elle
nous a dit enquête administrative
enquête judiciaire tu dis cela je dirais
que de toute façon nous serons assez
rapidement fixés puisque désormais le
parquet a été saisi de ces faits donc si
poursuit monsieur v dallas sur la base
des violences ça signifie qu'il y avait
bien une infraction au moment où tout le
monde a visionné cette vidéo le 2 mai
oui patrick kanner cefac que l'on
comprend en fait les autorités qui ne
voulaient pas saisir la retire 40 ne
savais pas que c'était un policier en
revanche est bien à l'elysée le savait
mais sûre c'est au mieux une omission au
pire une faute à nous de choisir en tout
cas à la justice de trancher en la
matière ce comportement est est il
admissible ça tout le monde le reconnaît
mais la vraie question c'est comment un
collaborateur chargé de mission du
président avec la proximité qui est la
sienne avec eux l'élysée et puisse
autoriser une telle démarche c'est une
forme d'impunité et il faut aussi
regarder les conséquences mais comment
en est on arrivé là
c'est tout le travail de la commission
d'enquêté du sénat je serai comme vous
fait réagir à nouveau c'était quand même
vraiment la grosse nouvelle d'hier la
question de la retenue sur salaire qui
va être faite seulement et bien du coup
à l'issue du avec le solde de tout
compte
alors qu'il y avait eu ces propos qui
laissait penser qu'effectivement eh bien
ils n'avaient
a eu de salaire pendant quinze jours oui
on a bien compris que monsieur jeu trop
d'à a été amené à dire la vérité parce
que nous voulons avoir accès aux fiches
de paye que comme nous aurons bien sûr
nous avons réitéré cette demande et donc
il a bien fallu voilà n'ont pas avoué
mais en tout cas dire la vérité
c'est une bonne chose pour notre
compréhension par contre manifestement
comme le dit très bien mais a toujours
d'un lac
est ce qu'il ya une véritable une
sanction et quand on parle de
rétrogradation dans la responsabilité
peut-être sur le papier mais dans les
faits benalla au 14 juillet ben alla au
panthéon benalla avec les bleus est
manifestement dans une logique très
autoritaire dans le fonctionnement du
passage du bus
donc ce monsieur encore une fois sans
les déclarations du monde le dévoilement
du monde serait aujourd'hui encore en
très grande responsabilité
opérationnelle au sein de la hiérarchie
de l'elysée et est-ce que vous avez cru
alexis cola lorsqu'il a indiqué que
finalement et bien il n'ya pas tant de
monde que cela pour gérer ce genre d'
immense opération que vient de citer
patrick kanner et que et bien toutes les
bonnes volontés sont les bienvenues dans
ces moments là c'est probable de n'avons
pas de raison de ne pas le croire il
témoigne en quelque sorte sous serment
donc il dit c'est nécessairement la
vérité mais à ce que du fait qu'on ait
besoin de sept personnes on en fera la
sanction qui a été prise
ils ouvraient également revient voir on
en a parlé tout à l'heure de cette
question des frictions des inimitiés
il ya eu ce moment où alexis kohler a
d'ailleurs assumé le fait qu'alexandre
aubenas puis savoir sont ses mots a un
profil différent on l'écouté on en
reparle juste après je n'ai que des que
des retours positifs sur son engagement
et son dévouement et je pense et le
présente à un public s'est exprimé sur
ce sujet hier est effectivement qui fait
écho à
un élément que fait valoir alexandre
benalla sur le fait c'était quelqu'un
qui avait un profil différent et c'est
tout à fait vrai qu alexandre dellal a
un profil différent par rapport à au
type de profil qu'on rencontre
fréquemment dans les couloirs de
l'elysée je pense que c'est aussi cet
opposant à publica dit que c'était
quelque chose ne pouvait être fier parce
que c'est important aussi que les
services la présence d'un public soit à
l'image de notre pays et le fait que
mais qu' il est il et il est un profil
evian ce qui est ce qui est en revanche
important c'est que chacun reste dans le
cadre de ses responsabilités et patrick
kanner alexandre benhaddad ans on
entretient dit que pour lui il ya
peut-être eu tort de vengeance un de la
caste contre lui parce que lui est
différent
une grande plaisanterie que dans des
services de l'état de l'elysée au
ministère en passant par les
administrations
on considère que la mixité sociale est
un plus naturellement par définition
simplement il faut mettre les bonnes
personnes aux bonnes places
est-ce qu'il avait les compétences pour
assurer les responsabilités quand lui
avait confié la preuve que non puisqu'il
a pété un plomb
ce 1er mai est confronté et qui ont
manifestement il ya une nappe était
ailleurs et dans d'autres circonstances
c'est ça la vraie question donc il peut
être qu'il fallait le remercier de son
engagement auprès du président pendant
la campagne électorale une honte à moi
je n'ai pas à en juger la vraie question
c'est que ce n'était pas quelqu'un qui
est d'acheter de la vaisselle deux
sèvres
il portait une arme dans la proximité
immédiate du président à quelqu'un qui
pète un plomb comme ça il peut aussi
pété un plomb dans son rôle de
protection
il protège le chef de l'état s'est pas
ils m'amènent le maquereau qui est en
cause nient l'histoire personnelle de
bagnac rond c'est la personne du chef de
l'état et nous avons nous raison
d'exiger que cette protection soit la
plus claire possible sur le terrain oui
donc jalousie peut-être mais jalousie
parce que dans sa fonction n'étaient pas
claires je crois qu'effectivement
président kader a raison on n'est pas en
terrain d'expérimentation à l'elysée les
institutions elles existent elles
préexiste et à un moment quelqu'un les
incarnent
mais pour autant ça ne peut pas être le
terrain sur lequel on fait strictement
ce que l'on veut ça dénote d'une façon
de gouverner quelque peu étrange je dois
dire que de penser que les institutions
doit s'adapter à la main d'un président
plutôt que celui ci les respecte telle
qu'elle existait deux sont définies par
la constitution à l'instar de protéger
l'individu mais de protéger
l'institution où tu as eu peur on va en
reparler juste après mais parce que ya
marine le pen qui nous attend micro de
jérôme rabier marine le pen qui a
assisté à cette audition
compte tenu du fait que il n'ya pas
d'audition d'alexis colère lors de la
commission d'enquêté de l'assemblée
nationale
oui avec marine le pen un député qui est
donc présente aujourd'hui au sénat pour
pouvoir finalement entendre la version
d'alexis colère sur d'éventuels
dysfonctionnements dans cette affaire
benalla oui bien sûr puisque la
commission denquête de l'assemblée
nationale présidée par madame il ya une
brune peavey en marche refuse d'accéder
aux demandes de l'opposition d'audition
au premier rang desquels existait bien
entendu la demande d'audition de
monsieur benalla lui-même qui vient de
donner une longue interview au monde
mais également celle de secrétaire
général de l'elysée celle de monsieur
castaner secrétaire général d'and marche
etc etc
bon je m'aperçois que la commission
d'audition la commission d' enquête du
sénat travaille de manière beaucoup plus
rigoureuse beaucoup plus professionnelle
beaucoup plus sérieuse et surtout
manifestement recherche l'émergence de
la vérité ce qui n'est pas le cas je le
regrette beaucoup
de la commission denquête à l'assemblée
nationale qu'est ce que vous avez appris
de cette audition aujourd'hui d'alexis
kohler il savait on apprend d'une
audition où on apprend de l'ensemble des
auditions je pense que l'intérêt qu'il y
ait de multiples auditions visant toute
la chaîne hiérarchique c'est qu'on finit
au fur et à mesure des auditions par
comprendre en réalité a effectivement ce
qui s'est passé et les
dysfonctionnements que je considère
comme très grave ou en tout cas les
projets que je considère comme très
grave qui était dans les cartons de
l'elysée et que peut-être
l'explosion de cette affaire a justifié
car je pense que c'est la création de
cette police parallèle à cette police
qui dépendra exclusivement du président
de la république et qui ne serait pas
constituée exclusivement de policiers de
gendarmes comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
qui peut-être a été à l'origine de la
révélation du comportement inadmissible
de monsieur benalla c'est pour arrêter
ce projet là en fait qu'ils ont envoyé
au monde ces éléments voilà ce que je
crois je crois que quand le ministre de
l'intérieur dit je pensais que monsieur
benalla était policier je pense que ça
n'est pas seulement un effet de défausse
je pense que c'est une manière pour lui
de dire ce monsieur se comportait comme
un policier il avait les attributions
d'un policier
il donnait des ordres à la hiérarchie
qu'elle soit d'ailleurs des de la
gendarmerie ou de la police
et cette situation manifestement
déplaisait profondément ministre de
l'intérieur qu'elle suit maintenant
donnez vous demander à la présidente à
l'assemblée nationale de reconvoquer
d'autres personnes que le sénat
poursuivre ses travaux
c'est quoi la suite mais le
co-rapporteur monsieur l'arrivée à
exprimer je crois la voix de l'ensemble
de l'opposition réclamant toute une
série d'auditions est ce qu'il est
croyez-vous légitime que la présidente
en marche d'abord préside une commission
denquête qui quand même concerne le
président
ancien président marc président de la
république aujourd'hui et le secrétaire
général d'and marche monsieur castaner
et refuse l intégralité d audition
demandée par l'opposition
alors oui ça doit sûrement fonctionner
je pense en corée du nord ou des choses
comme ça et d'ailleurs des pays où on
peut trouver peut-être des commission
denquête où les gens enquêtes sur eux
mêmes en entendant personnes sur moi ça
doit encore exister dans quelques coins
du monde mais pas en france merci marine
le pen d'avoir répondu à nos questions
en direct sur public sénat merci
beaucoup jérôme pour cette nouvelle
réaction patrick kanner je vous fait
réagir déjà à la présence de marine le
pen dans l'assistance elle n'était pas
la salle il y avait par exemple valérie
rabault présidente du groupe nouvelle
gauche à l'assemblée nationale
mais la présence de marine le pen
peut-être il ya aussi une fonction de
communication dans cette présence de
marine la pluie elle est venue on va pas
lui en faire le reproche la commission
et public il peut être que d'autres
députés de toutes sensibilités aurait pu
venir pour écouter monsieur colère
puisque finalement le sénat rattrape le
coup manqué de l'assemblée nationale moi
je regrette que la majorité en marche
n'est pas souhaité auditionner monsieur
colère qui s'est pliée d'ailleurs tout à
fait aux jeux on peut être plus ou moins
satisfait de ses réponses mais il s'est
plié au jeu démocratique et qu'il 2h30
2h30 donc ouais je n'ai rien à reprocher
à monsieur secrétaire général en tout
cas au moins sur la forme sur la
présence de madame le pen voilà donc
nous la connaissons elle fait beaucoup
de communication
elle reste néanmoins une leader de la
droite extrême dans notre dans notre
pays
et quand elle fait des comparaisons un
peu osé j'aurais dû nord où d'autres ou
d'autres exemples voilà à cesser son
mode de communication mais elle est
venue et elle a écouté je l' ai vu ce
qu'elle était dans mon angle de vue
elle a écouté les deux heures et demie
d'audition dont tact et muriel jourda et
bien marine le pen à la presser des
louanges à la commission d' enquête du
sénat au fait que et bien les auditions
se poursuivent dans le calme on voit
quelques amis des informations qui
sortent même si ce n'est pas facile il
faut vraiment posé et reposé la question
il ya clairement une différence de
climat entre la commission d' enquête du
sénat et celle de l'assemblée nationale
clairement clairement j'ai effectivement
regarder des auditions de l'assemblée
nationale pour préparer nos propres
auditions il est assez évident que de
manière générale au sénat même si ce
type maison je fréquente depuis quelques
mois seulement il y a plutôt un climat
de travail et d'apaisement
quelles que soient nos opinions
politiques et parfois nos clivages qui
réapparaissent quand même d'en haut
certaines discussions mais il ya un
climat de travail d'apaisement et de
souhait de faire aboutir cette
commission denquête notamment qui fait
que c'est plus simple de travailler
ensemble et c'est plus simple de
convoquer qui nous devons convoqué c'est
aussi plus simple parce que les
majorités ne sont pas les mêmes et que
effectivement et bien la république en
marche est très majoritaire à
l'assemblée nationale on peut comprendre
que les travaux aient plus de
difficultés dans ce contexte à ce que
pour vous c'est normal patrice explique
pour cette raison pas qu'une question de
rapport de force majoritaire ou
minoritaire
c'est aussi le fait que les sénateurs
ont un parcours personnel liées souvent
à des mandats locaux des responsabilités
locales importantes nous sommes voilà
nous sommes formatés par la république
au travers des responsabilités qu'ont pu
être les nôtres qu'ils sont encore les
nôtres aujourd'hui on voit bien que que
la semaine nationale on a beaucoup de
jeunes députés qui finiront par vieillir
et prendre de l'expérience mais qui sont
un peu à l'image de leur chef
c'est un peu le message qui nous a donné
manuel macron il ya 48 heures devant les
députés réunis à la maison de l'amérique
latine avec cette expression
voilà ci sont pas contents quitte vienne
me chercher tout le monde n'est pas
mirabeau parce qu'il faisait référence
sûrement
à la salle du jeu de paume ou mirabeau
avait dit mais nous sommes là par la
volonté du peuple n'en sortiront que par
la force des baïonnettes
tout le monde n'est pas mirabeau il faut
faire attention aux raccourcis en la
matière et parmi les parlementaires qui
assistait à ce fameux discours des
manuels macron à cette première prise de
parole présidentiel sur l affaire
benalla il y avait le sénateur françois
patriat
il s'est exprimé tout à l'heure au micro
de jérôme rabier on l'écoutait oui avec
françois patriat lé le patron du groupe
la république en marche
ici au sénat alors françois patriat vous
avez écouté à lecci colère le secrétaire
général de l'elysée qu'est ce que vous
retenez de cette audition sur la forme
de la commission je note que le ton est
plus apaisée plus mesuré plus
responsables avec peut-être moins
d'agressivité qui a pu avoir au début
alexis kohler vient après la venue de
6,3 à hier il ya une parfaite
complémentarité entre les réponses qui
sont apportées on tourne un peu en rond
parce qu'on leur pose les mêmes
questions
alors que les réponses sont déjà connues
et qu'ils sont réitéré ce matin par
alexis kohler beaucoup de lucidité
beaucoup de clarté
je crois que le secrétaire général dont
on connaît le talent la tâche redoutable
le nom
fonction qu'il occupe aujourd'hui a
donné avec beaucoup de sincérité
les réponses aux questions qui lui
étaient posées tant sur l'organisation
sur le rôle de monsieur mais nahla sur
sa fonction sur son recrutement sur la
photo il a surtout rappelé ce matin
comment fonctionne d'elysée avec les
tâches qui les soutient compte la
répartition des tâches et son rôle à lui
je crois qu'il le fait avec beaucoup de
transparence et que c'est de nature à
apporter des explications à tous ceux
qui se posaient des questions
la commission denquête à l'assemblée
nationale n'a pas souhaité l'entendre
est ce que c'est une bonne chose qu'ici
au sénat au moins ça clarifie les
responsabilités à l'elysée je sais pas
quelles sont les raisons pour
l'assemblée nationale je siège ici au
sénat je sais que l'invitation d'alexis
colère était prématurée était déjà fait
depuis lundi qu'il y a répondu
immédiatement que cette 7e venue était
prévue depuis trois jours elle
intervient ce matin dans un calme climat
plus apaisé
je pense que c'est de l'est de bonne
tenue dans l'acte de la commission et
dans le même temps ça permet de
corroborer des réponses que nous avions
déjà
est ce que pour vous on s'approche de la
vérité dans cette affaire grâce à aux
travaux de la roche crois qu'aujourd'hui
tout le monde connaît la vérité c'est il
s'agit d'un événement malheureux
choquant mais qui n'est qu'un événement
khiter dérapage personnel d'un chargé de
mission à l'elysée qu'il reconnaisse
m'attaque il a fait une très grosse
bêtise il faut laisser cela pour ce que
c'est non pas pour pour une affaire
d'état comme certains voudraient encore
le faire croire aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup françois patriat
président du groupe la république en
marche
ici au sénat d'avoir répondu à nos
questions voilà pour cette interview de
françois patriat médias jour d'âge vous
faire réagir
est ce qu'on y voit beaucoup plus clair
pour un fonds sera patriat c'est évident
c'est une pure fautes individuelles une
grosse bêtise pour reprendre les propos
d'alexandre benalla dans son entretien
au monde aujourd'hui alors police
parallèle ou amateurisme
dysfonctionnements au coeur du pouvoir
où véritable affaire d'état
écoutez d'abord sur sur ces faits eux
mêmes je crois que nous avons une
enquête judiciaire en cours sur les
faits de violences puis ce qu'on peut
qualifier ça ainsi nous avons donc à
dives et judicieux en quoi je dirais que
même si nous suivions le ce que dit
françois patriat c'est à dire que c'est
un dérapage personnel
ça pose question de savoir comment on
dans l'entourage du président nous
pouvons avoir quelqu'un qui est capable
à ce point de sortir de sa fonction et
peut-être de mettre en danger et
éventuellement le président de la
république un jour en sortant de sa
fonction ainsi puisqu'on a vu que
c'était quelqu'un qui était intervenu ça
s'était établi clairement en pensant
qu'il y avait des débordements alors
qu'il n'y en avait pas le jour de la
manifestation avec des gestes techniques
mal maîtrisées deux ont dit tous les
professionnels
donc de ce point de vue là même si on
estime que c'est un dérapage personnel
il pose la question de l'organisation de
la sécurité du président de la
république où il joue comme un rôle
manifestement majeur si l'on regarde
simplement les photos sur lesquelles il
se trouve être à kenner oui ce n'est pas
qu'un fait divers isolé
c'est un chargé de mission très proche
du président de la république qui a
commis ces faits mais derrière cela
c'est symptomatique d'un fonctionnement
de cette hyper centralisation du pouvoir
que nous connaissons depuis maintenant
un an
notre collègue sénateur socialiste jean
yves le conte imposer une très bonne
question sur les conseillers communs
entre l'elysée et
et matignon c'est la première fois a
rappelé philippe bas que cela se fait
dans la vème république
sacré de la confusion et ça montre
qu'elle est la conception du pouvoir
finalement confusion des genres de la
république eh bien écoutez on va
également repasser par le foyer
clemenceau puisque jérôme un rabier
c'est trop avec le sénateur et c'est
loïc hervé qui a lui aussi assisté à
cette audition jérôme rhabiller jérôme
c'est à vous willow et loïc hervé qui a
pu suivre cette audition d'alexis kohler
qu'est ce que vous avez retenu le garder
de cette audition ce qui est très
intéressant c'est d'entendre le
secrétaire général de l'elysée après le
directeur de cabinet qui nous avons
auditionné hier soir et de faire le
point avec lui de cette affaire abena la
vue de l'intérieur de la présidence de
la république donc sur un plan de
l'organisation même de la présidence de
la république et des du jeu d'acteur qui
a été celui après les la sphère du 1er
mai est intéressante d'avoir d'avoir son
avis et son éclairage sur ce qui s'est
passé sur des choses tout à fait
concrète qui tiennent à la sanction et
aux modalités de la sanction de monsieur
benalla comme aux conséquences qu'on
peut tirer de cette affaire dans
l'organisation même de l'exécutif en
france
cette audition elle était nécessaire on
sait qu'elle a fait débat au titre de la
séparation des pouvoirs elle était
nécessaire pour faire émerger la vérité
elle était absolument nécessaire puisque
dans les fonctions du parlement le
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement et
de l'exécutif au centre d'hardelot si
effectivement une question de deux murs
constitutionnel vis-à-vis de la
présidence de la république
ça me paraissait essentiel parce que
monsieur colère monsieur strada hier
soir sont des personnes qui ont été
amenés à prendre des décisions ou à
rendre compte ou à échanger que le
président la république sur la sanction
de monsieur beynat la suite la sphère du
1er mai après cette première semaine
d'auditions est ce que vous avez déjà
une idée de la direction si vous avez
déjà découvert des dysfonctionnements
qu'est ce que vous retenez de cette
première semaine d'auditions la première
chose que je retiens c'est que monsieur
benalla n'a pas été sanctionné sur
l'implant autre que formel il a été mis
à pied mais il n'a pas été démis de ses
fonctions il n'a pas purgé ses quinze
jours entre guillemets de mises à pied
elles seront ses quinze jours seront
retenus sur ses congés de 2017 fallait
qu'il y ait une commission d enquête
parlementaire pour s'en rendre compte ce
qui est quelque chose de tout à fait
paradoxale en tout cas inquiétants
deuxièmement je pense que sur le
professionnalisme de ceux qui s'occupent
de la sécurité du palais l'elysée de la
personne du président de la république
c'est important qu'on ait des des
garanties que ces personnes là soit des
militaires de la gendarmerie ou des
personnes appartenant à la police où que
ce soit des par des personnes
appartenant au corps préfectoral et pas
des personnes recrutées après une
campagne électorale pour phase pourrait
assumer ces fonctions là c'est personnel
peuvent et éventuellement la demande
avec d'un cabinet ou au sens politique
du terme mais ne pas s'occuper de
fonctions techniques dans la protection
rapprochée président la république ça me
paraît quelque chose qui aujourd'hui
nous saute aux yeux en plein milieu de
cette audition il ya une information le
monde a publié une interview de monsieur
benalla est ce que pour vous maintenant
il faut l'entendre aussi au sénat pour
avoir son éclairage je sais pas s'il
faut tendre alexandre benalla devant
devant une commission d'enquêté
parlementaire on en a parlé au sein de
la commission de l'eau des lois pour
l'instant ce qui est certain c'est que
ça révèle pour nous en tout cas pour moi
en tant que parlementaire une très
grande frustration de voir que d'une
part le président de la république
réserve ses déclarations à la république
en marché au modem à la maison
d'amérique latine avant-hier soir à une
déclaration sur le terrain dans le
sud-ouest
hier et que monsieur benalla lui choisi
un grand quotidien du soir donc on a les
meilleurs morceaux de son interview ce
matin et on les aura dans l'accord
n'aura l'intégralité de l'interview ce
après midi
je sais pas ce qu'on apprendra de plus
en tout cas aujourd'hui on est dans le
commentaire du commentaire et s'est pas
sain parce que il ya une enquête
judiciaire qui est en cours il ya une
enquête parlementaire l'assemblée au
sénat qui est en cours il ya eu des
choses qu'ils sont blancs l'imaginer au
plan administratif ou disciplinaire
qu'on ait un peu de rigueur là dedans
c'est un peu la demande que je formule à
l'égard du du président de la république
comme de monsieur b nérac on connaît
aussi du sérieux dans la manière dont
l'exécutif où monsieur bénac et mis en
cause puisse traiter la communication
vis-à-vis de ces différentes
institutions de la république merci loïc
hervé d'avoir répondu à nos questions
oui merci beaucoup jérôme pour cette
nouvelle réaction c'est une affaire
mêlant jourda qui reflète donc on le
disait la confusion des genres la
confusion peut être même des pouvoirs ce
qui est d'autant plus marquant que et
bien alexis kohler comme patrick strzoda
hier ont tout de suite parlé au
contraire de séparation des pouvoirs
quand ils ont commencé leur audition en
disant qu'ils avaient été en plus
autorisée par le président de la
république à venir répondre aux
questions des sénateurs alors même
qu'ils y sont tenus par le statut d'une
commission denquête oui alors il parle
de la séparation du pouvoir exécutif et
du pouvoir législatif bennoo ce que nous
pointons du doigt c'est la façon dont le
tessin des le pouvoir exécutif qui est
le président de la république d'un côté
et les ministres de l'autre dont dépend
l'administration et notamment
l'administration qui s'occupe aussi de
la sécurité du président la république
or là on introduit un élément proche du
président de la république qui est
finalement pas se substituer à
l'autorité des ministères alors ça peut
paraître assez compliqué à comprendre
je dirais lorsqu'on est pas familier de
la constitution mais c'est un
déséquilibre des pouvoirs et y est on ne
doit pas le toucher ainsi et le modifier
a à la faveur du encore une fois d'une
expérimentation pour faire entrer la
diversité au sein du gouvernement
patrick kanner qu'est-ce que vous
inspire donc cette affaire benalla au
regard de ce principe fondamental de la
séparation des pouvoirs
une
très belle citation que je vous dise
tout homme qui a du pouvoir est porté à
en abuser pour qu'on ne puisse abuser du
pouvoir il faut que par la disposition
des choses le pouvoir arrête le pouvoir
montesquieu l'esprit des lois voilà je
pense qu'il faut vraiment que le public
regarde cette phrase ses phrases parce
que ce que nous demandons c'est pas
d'affaiblir le pouvoir du président de
la république c'est qu'il y ait des
contre-pouvoirs qui permette à la
république de bien fonctionner et on
sent bien une forme sinon
d'autoritarisme
en tout cas de concentrations
personnelle du pouvoir qui peut aboutir
à ce type de dysfonctionnement donc la
ferme et dana ce n'est pas que la sphère
des nanas c'est peut-être la conception
qui est celle de monsieur macron de sa
fonction de président de la république
oui et elle rejaillit bien sûr sur à
bien la réforme en cours la révision
constitutionnelle muriel jourda
cela apporte de l'eau à votre moulin
cette affaire alors de fait déjà leur
vie ont constitué a été arrêté à
l'assemblée nationale puisqu'ils ont été
incapables de continuer sur ce débat
tant que la commission denquête n'était
pas terminée 280 18 rappels au règlement
la semaine dernière la paralysie totale
dans l'hémicycle exactement je crois que
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
inédit dans la vème république
et puis ça effectivement apporte de
l'eau à notre moulin dans le sens où
notre boule est notre moulin tournait
dans le sens de m'indiquer qu'il fallait
être extrêmement attentif à cet
équilibre des pouvoirs dont parlait le
président caennais que le parlement en
fait partie et qu'aujourd'hui la réforme
et dans l'idée d'affaiblir le parlement
au prétexte je dirais pas motivé au
prétexte de mieux faire la loi
alors qu'on voit bien que le parlement
est un rouage essentiel pour faire front
face à un exécutif qui aurait peut-être
des velléités de prendre une tasse trop
importante
patrick kanner le mot de la fin sur la
question de la révision
constitutionnelle
je reprendrai ma ma réplique au premier
ministre cette semaine dans les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
ce prêt ministre retiré votre réforme
telle qu'elle est j'ai envie de lui dire
installer une commission des sages comme
elle existait pour la réforme sarkozy
autour de monsieur balladur nous serons
prêts à travailler pour une belle
réforme constitutionnelle qui donne plus
de place aux citoyens et qui surtout
préserve ce qui est essentiel pour moi
et madame jourdain la halle équilibre
des pouvoirs saindor syndrome finalement
d'une république qui fonctionne eh bien
merci beaucoup patrick kanner président
du groupe socialiste au sénat et muriel
jourda rapporteur et l'air de cette
commission d' enquête sur la sphère
alexandre benalla je précise que les
auditions vont se poursuivre encore la
semaine prochaine toujours autour de la
sphère alexandre benalla merci beaucoup
d'être venus a commenté l'audition cette
audition phare celle d'alexis colère le
secrétaire général de l'elysée et avant
de se quitter je vous propose de voir
également bien la réaction de françois
noël buffet sénateur républicain
il était tout à l'heure au micro de
jérôme radiés oui avec françois noël
buffet membre de la commission des lois
vous avez pu entendre ce matin alexis
kohler le secrétaire général de l'elysée
qu'est ce que vous avez appris de
nouveau écoutez nous n'avons pas appris
des choses très nouvelles si ce n'est
peut-être une confirmation qui élit en
réalité un événement extérieur à savoir
que monsieur benalla a fait une
déclaration dans la presse
aujourd'hui on a dit quand mike fay ce
qui prouve à l'évidence qu'il s'occupait
de la sécurité du président de la
république qu'il y avait des tensions
avec le groupement de protection du
président de la république c'est un vrai
sujet cela nous avait été dit par les
syndicats de police se lavait était
semble-t-il n'était pas la connaissance
les différents dirigeants de palais de
l'elysée celle de directeur de cabinet
ou même du secrétaire-général de films
alice matin c'est donc bien la preuve
que petit à petit cette enquête nous
permet de révéler la véritable situation
son véritable rôle et nous avons quand
même établi des dysfonctionnements des
dysfonctionnements sur sept ce port
d'armes tout à faire
étonnant des désaccords dans les
déclarations qui ont été faites à
certains points de vue sa situation
juridique y compris la sanction telle
qu'elle a été en tous les cas annoncés
mais pas appliquée l'émission les
contradictions dans l'émission de qui là
qui étaient les siennes par les actes de
ce contrat de travail
donc nous avons besoin maintenant
d'obtenir les pièces d'avoir les
documents pour se finir de cette
instruction gelé dire parlementaire qui
devrait nous amener à la vérité nous
avons besoin de valider c'était bien
nécessaire que le sénat convoque alexis
kohler contrairement à l'assemblée qui
s'y est opposée oui c'était absolument
nécessaire que la commission denquête
plus entendre le secrétaire général de
l'elysée il a un rôle premier au sein
évidemment à du palais il est le premier
collaborateur du président de la
république
il a donc évidemment à connaître de
l'ensemble de ces situations et ses
déclarations étaient d'importance mais
évidemment maintenant les prochaines
étapes c'est quoi vous attendez le
rapport de l'igpn vous allez continuez
votre travail dans quête pas encore nous
continuons les auditions évidemment bien
sûr il ne faut pas s'arrêter
nous aurons le maurupt sans doute le
rapport de l'igpn je rappelle que la
commission s'est donné plusieurs mois ne
s'est pas mis la pression sur ses
expressions pour rendre son rapport
et comme à l'image du sénat c'est avec
beaucoup de sérénité beaucoup de
détermination et avec le temps qu'il
faudra pour faire jaillir la vérité sur
cette affaire
merci beaucoup françois noël buffet
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
voilà pour cette interview de françois
noël buffet c'est la fin de cette
émission consacrée à la commission d'
enquête sénatoriale sur la sphère
benalla et l'audition d'alexis colère le
secrétaire général de l'elysée je vous
précise que l'assemblée nationale
poursuit elle aussi ses auditions et
vous pourrez les suivre en direct sur
les chaînes parlementaires cet après
midi très bonne fin de journée sur les
chaînes parlementaires
[Musique]